Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Hier spricht Tim.
Das ist ähm wie schon in der letzten Sendung der vierte März zwanzig zweiundzwanzig, denn wir machen heute gleich mal zwei Sendungen auf einmal,
nachdem wir die eine Krise jetzt ad acta gelegt haben und es ja immer gilt, ne, nach der Krise ist vor der Krise, wollen wir uns dann tatsächlich mal dem.
In der Ukraine zuwenden. Das Thema, was uns, glaube ich, allen gerade so im Kopf äh hängt.
Und dann stellt sich natürlich so ein bisschen wieder so wie vor zwei Jahren die Frage so, okay,
Habt ihr da eigentlich dazu zu sagen? Ich sage jetzt mal hallo Pavel.
Ja, hallo Tim.
An meiner Seite äh erinnerst du dich noch, wie wir uns legitimieren mussten am Anfang?
Ja ja genau. Was qualifiziert uns eigentlich überhaupt äh irgendwie äh ja darüber zu reden über dieses dieses Thema?
Ja, ich fange mal mit mir an. Also bei bei mir ist noch weniger.
Also ich habe hm generell so als West im Westen aufgewachsener Mensch.
Und das halt auch noch in diesen kriegsfreien Nachkriegsjagen.
Dich irgendwie so ähm aktiv sagen wir mal so Jugendzeit äh Achtziger, 90erjahre äh vor allem äh erlebt habe.
Relativ wenig Ost-Europa-Bezug generell. So, ich spreche kein Russisch. Ich hatte.
Lange lange Zeit gedauert, bis ich überhaupt das erste Mal meinen Fuß in die DDR gesetzt habe. Ähm das war erst ganz kurz vorm Maueröffnung.
Und ähm ja weiß nicht, ich bin halt so klassisch westorientiert so, ich kenne Westeuropa relativ gut und ich kenne Osteuropa.
Naja, ich sage mal kaum. Ja, ich war hier und da ähm in der Ukraine war ich nie. Ich war auch nicht in Russland.
Ähm mir ist auch das Ganze Sklavische sprach ähm Gebäude.
Tendenziell eher unbekannt. Ich kann's nicht lesen. Ich komme auch mit der krylischen äh Schrift kaum klar. Und ich glaube, so geht's vielen. So, ne. Natürlich begleite ich.
Das Weltgeschehen und wer hat mir zu dem einen oder anderen so eine Meinung gebildet, aber
Ich habe da letztlich genauso wenig von vorgeahnt ähm wie die meisten auch. Klar, es war immer alles irgendwie möglich, aber,
Genauso gut hätte es auch zu keiner Eskalation kommen können und ich hätte's genau hätte genauso wenig Geld damit gewonnen.
Aber bei dir ist es ein bisschen anders, Pavel, ne?
Mir so ein paar Dinge, denke ich. Gut, zum einen bin ich in Prag geboren und habe da auch eine Menge
Zeit verbracht und äh bin letztlich äh irgendwo, ich sage mal, auch slavischer Abstammung, äh wenn man so will und äh ja gut Ukrainer kenne ich halt äh vor allem jetzt direkt
aus Tschechien, wo die quasi dieselbe Rolle spielten wie in Deutschland so ein bisschen die Polen, das heißt so als günstige Arbeitskräfte und und und Handwerker fürs fürs Grobe.
So. Das war so ein bisschen wie ich eigentlich äh zum ersten Mal auf die Ukraine aufmerksam geworden bin, aber
Ähm ja es gibt halt dann schon so gewisse kulturelle Eigenheiten, auch vor allen Dingen familiär und dann natürlich ja
ähm so dieser dieser ganze Ostblock äh oder Postsowjetische Ostblock, dann mit äh Korruption und,
Beziehungen und so, das ist mir halt alles nicht fremd. Des Weiteren äh ja äh war ich.
Bei der Bundeswehr, obwohl ich irgendwie zwei Staatsbürgerschaften habe, dachte ich, müsste ich nicht äh so. Die Tschechen wollten mich nicht, wobei die haben mich dann vorgeladen irgendwie äh sogar in Tschechien, um mir zu erklären, dass sie mich nicht
einsetzen werden, aber die äh Bundeswehr hatte da keine Skrupel oder keine Befürchtung, dass
irgendwie dann vielleicht äh sozusagen im Kriegsfall irgendwie Hemmungen hätte jetzt auf meine Verwandten äh
in Tschechien zu schießen oder irgendwie keine Ahnung Geheimnisse ausplaudern würde. Aber die Tschechen waren da eher so äh ja ja nee nee also den wollen wir nicht
äh irgendwie, dass es uns zu zu heikel so und ja und äh so als.
Lasst mich kurz dazu noch sagen, ich war natürlich auch nicht bei der Bundeswehr. Also ich habe auch überhaupt gar keine Militärerfahrung.
Also ich als wie gesagt als halber Ausländer äh musste aber hin, beziehungsweise
ich hätte natürlich auch verweigern können, aber so als 19-jähriger unsterblicher oder sich unsterblich äh fühlender äh junger Mann. So habe ich das halt so ein bisschen,
Abenteuerspielplatz äh dann auch für mich gesehen und so ja da gab's halt irgendwie,
Autos zum Rumfahren im Gelände und Waffen und man konnte Dinge explodieren lassen und außerdem habe ich dann irgendwie ein Kreuzchen gemacht,
willig, was dazu führte, dass ich dann halt äh ja zu einem äh Fallschirmjäger-Battaillon in Iserlohn
eingezogen wurde und dann halt sogar noch mehr Spaß äh hatte, nämlich äh nicht sagen, gehöre ich zu den Leuten, die halt öfter mit einem Flugzeug gestartet sind, als sie gelandet sind.
Bei mir hält sich's die Waage.
So und äh ja auch auch ansonsten ja äh also ich,
hatte schon, wie ich meine, gut, ich es hätte nicht unbedingt sein müssen, aber äh so rückblickend, also ich hatte hatte halt meinen Spaß und es war eine interessante
Erfahrung so kennenzulernen, Militär von innen und insbesondere die Bundeswehr.
Wobei auch eben damals äh schon äh äh galt äh so das äh die Hauptaufgabe der Bundeswehr war, den Feind so lange zu verwirren bis richtiges Militär eintrifft.
Und äh ja, das ist seitdem fast noch eher schlimmer geworden. Also mein aber damals war's auch so
die Bundeswehr war eine reine Abschreckungsarmee und tatsächlich die offizielle Doktrin war ähm wenn es jemals zum Krieg kommen sollte
also wenn die Bundeswehr jemals in den Krieg ziehen sollte, hat sie eigentlich ihre Aufgabe schon verfehlt. Also es verging nicht um Krieg führen, sondern um
abschrecken und dazu musste man aber natürlich so tun, als ob man in der Lage wäre, Krieg zu führen. Aber das ist so na ja, so so halb gelungen und ich dachte mir halt immer nur, wenn ich da war,
äh
Hoffentlich muss ich mit dieser Truppe niemals in den Krieg ziehen, weil das das also ich hatte nicht das Gefühl, dass das irgendwie jetzt äh ja irgendwie ein besonders äh schlagkräftiges
äh äh Militär war, sondern gut, Militär ist sowieso grundsätzlich jede Menge Fuck-up, äh weil äh das ist halt jetzt auch nicht
unbedingt durchsetzt so gerade in den Rängen jetzt von besonderen ja
soll man sagen intellektuellen Größen unbedingt, sondern und die ganze Struktur ist auch so, das muss halt für jeden funktionieren so, das ist alles wie alles sehr vereinfacht, alles sehr standardisiert und dementsprechend natürlich geht auch
unglaublich viel schief. So also selbst äh äh deswegen gab's halt zum Beispiel für tausend Kilometer unfallfreies Fahren gab's halt einen Tag Sonderurlaub.
So nur um allein das Niveau der der Fahrkünste äh sagen äh und und nicht viele haben.
Was fahren? Mit was fahren im.
Autos, also PKWs, also äh so PKWs, äh Unimog, LKWs, äh
oder Jeeps, was auch immer, egal was, ja und führst halt auch ein Fahrtenbuch und deswegen ja, ich weiß gar nicht wie viel, ich glaube, ich habe sieben oder acht Tage äh allein äh Sonderurlaub
äh deswegen gekriegt, weil ich keine Unfälle gebaut habe. So also es war halt also das Niveau war jetzt nicht besonders.
Keine oder nur wenige.
Nein, nein, gar keine. Ja gut, ja, will jetzt nicht zu lange irgendwie Geschichten vom vom irgendwie Krieg
erzählen, aber ja und ich und ich kann natürlich von meinen ganzen Verwandten ausm Osten natürlich auch die ganzen Geschichten wie Fakt ab,
eigentlich äh Wehrdienst im Osten äh so war. Er hat ja halt viel länger gedauert hat und wo man wenig Rücksicht genommen hat äh auch auf die Leute. Es war halt,
ziemlich gefährlich äh so. Ähm also da sind auch viele Leute einfach so verletzt worden oder drauf gegangen beim beim,
Wehrdienst, so dass das war beim beim Bund nicht so gerne gesehen, so dass da galt halt auch äh eher mehr so Sicherheit.
So, ja. Also wie gesagt, ich habe halt ich kenne mich halt ein bisschen äh aus äh deswegen auch auch praktisch so,
mit Waffen und Waffensystemen und und so ein bisschen mit mit Krieg. Naja und dann.
Habe ich halt äh später noch äh irgendwann habe ich habe ich halt auch so ein bisschen im Verteidigungsbereich mich mich getummelt, also grob im.
Bereich, im Sicherheitsforschungsbereich, wo ich dann auch nochmal ähm
ja die Bundeswehr auf einem auf einem höheren Level erlebt habe, zum Beispiel kenne ich ganz gut das Einsatzführungskommando der Bundeswehr in in Potsdam, wo die ganzen äh Einsätze geführt sind, aber auch so ein bisschen die die
Struktur im im Bundesverteidigungsministeriumsministerium und so wie das, wie das da alles läuft und das ist das ist ganz furchtbar so. Deswegen habe ich mich da auch wieder wieder rausgezogen, weil das ist das ist auch schlimm.
Und deswegen graust du mir auch die Aussicht, dass da jetzt nochmal irgendwie hundert Milliarden äh draufgeworfen werden, auf eine Struktur, die,
es seit Jahrzehnten nicht mal schafft,
Eindruck ein von einsatzfähigen Militär zu erwecken, ja? Dabei ist das also sie müssten ja gar nicht wirklich, sondern die müssen ja eigentlich müssten ja eigentlich nur tun, als ob.
Aber selbst das äh äh gelingt halt äh nicht wirklich, ja. Und wenn's nach mir ginge, äh würde ich das gesamte Bundesverteidigungsministerium äh äh komplett,
machen, alle rauswerfen und komplett von vorne neu aufbauen so, weil äh ich glaube nicht, dass wenn wir da jetzt jetzt nochmal fünfzig Milliarden draufwerfen, äh dass dass das dann irgendwie großartig besser
wird, so deswegen bin ich da auch so ein bisschen bisschen skeptisch, ja. Und dann habe ich natürlich,
wie auch bei Covid dieselbe Bewältigungs- äh Strategie, dass immer wenn mir irgendwas Angst macht oder wenn ich irgendwas nicht verstehe, dann äh beginne ich mich
exzessiv äh da hinein äh zu arbeiten und zu denken und alle Informationen aufzusaugen und wieder auszuspucken. Und äh ja.
Und das ist das, was wir jetzt genau das, was wir jetzt tun. So, damit sind wir, glaube ich, durch mit dem Vorwort und können jetzt, glaube ich, eigentlich mitten
äh einsteigen, oder? Wie siehst du das.
Ja. Äh vielleicht noch ein äh Satz dazu. Mir geht's auch ähnlich, muss aber auch zugeben, ich habe ähm.
Auch grade so einen anderen mit anderen Dingen beschäftigt waren, die mich so wunderbar mal aus allem rausgeholt haben.
Auch so die ersten zwei Tage habe ich auch so ein bisschen mein mein Dinei irgendwie erstmal durchgeführt und ich glaube das ging auch vielen Leuten so, dass dass so dieses so oh Gott nee jetzt nicht nicht wirklich jetzt haben sie das nicht wirklich getan so ne.
Und äh grade gerade jetzt, wo wir irgendwie.
Pandemie durch irgendwie ist einfach der Bedarf für Katastrophen auch wirklich äh ausreichend gedeckt und dann so
wenden jetzt irgendwie noch so ein Ding hinterher mit so potenziellen Nukleartod äh ausblicken. Ich glaube, da machen viele auch erst mal den Kopf zu. Und,
mir ging's dann im Kleinen erstmal so, dass ich auch einfach erstmal so zwei Tage wollte ich erstmal gar nicht hören, dass das
weil ich natürlich auch befürchtet habe wie alle dass es dann auch irgendwie in zwei Tagen auch schon alles ganz schlimm ist.
Also es ist dann irgendwie vorbei und äh getan ist, was in gewisser Hinsicht natürlich auch ein Segen wäre, aber ähm.
Ja, so und dann bin ich natürlich auch genau in den selben Modus gekommen wie du. Da hat's zwar allerdings schon äh Vorsprung schon deine ersten paar Twitter-Freads äh draußen.
Ja ja. Ich muss äh ehrlicherweise auch sagen, dass ich das auch nicht
erwartet hatte, äh dass er einmarschieren wird. Also ich habe dem eher eine geringe Wahrscheinlichkeit gegeben, wobei sozusagen meine, sage mal, auf auf Twitter auch dokumentierte Meinung
so vorher war,
Ja wir werden den Russen wohl irgendwas geben müssen, weil sonst marschieren sie früher oder später.
Ein. So, aber ich hatte Putin äh da äh überschätzt oder oder seine.
Falsch eingeschätzt und muss sagen, ich gehörte eigentlich vorher auch eher so ein bisschen zu den Putin-Verstehern oder Russland-Verstehern, weil ich ja schon ein bisschen mehr Verständnis für die Situation habe, auch weil
Ähm ja ich ein paar ganz gute russische Freunde habe ähm so.
Deren Sicht auch ganz gut kenne und wie halt äh ja die die die Russen äh das sehen und warum sie Putin äh mögen und soll sich,
kenne halt die russische Perspektive so ein so ein bisschen auch und deswegen hatte ich halt auch immer,
eher so so Verständnis und tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen ja Respekt, wenn ich da
Bewunderung für für Putin, wie der das da alles alles managt und äh es schafft
auch so das das Land hinter sich zu halten und irgendwie mit mit Zustimmungsraten von
achtzig, 90 Prozent ist nie unter 65 Prozent gesunken. So und deswegen dachte ich, eigentlich ist der ist der zu cool, um
so ein so ein Unsinn zu machen, aber da habe ich mich halt tatsächlich äh auch auch getäuscht äh so. Ja.
Bisher in guter Gesellschaft. Ich ähm hatte jetzt keine Erwartung bei ihm konkretes ähm deswegen habe ich mich da auch nicht unbedingt verschätzt.
Ja, na gut. Dann mach mal einen Vorschlag, wie wie wollen wir uns denn diesem Thema jetzt überhaupt.
Nähern. Also es ist,
ich glaube man muss erstmal so ein bisschen so diese, ich meine du meinst du du verstehst die russische Perspektive ja oder mein mein Test die russische Perspektive,
in Teilaspekten zu verstehen oder vielleicht erst mal so ein bisschen, ich will also wir wollen jetzt hier keinen Geschichts-Podcast machen. Ähm vielleicht sollten wir nochmal so ein bisschen was zu unserer Zielsetzung sagen. Wir wollen.
Ganze mit unseren Gedanken.
Begleiten. Ja, wir machen jetzt hier wieder einen Geschichts-Podcast, noch ein Militär-Podcast, noch irgendwie ein News-Podcast zu dem Thema.
Sondern wir wollen einfach so ein bisschen unsere Beobachtung, Einschätzung äh und damit natürlich auch so unsere eigene Bewältigung mit mit der Situation.
Äh hörbar machen und euch einladen, hier quasi mit zu.
Denken und eure Meinung oder auch eure Befürchtungen oder Hoffnungen daran auch in irgendeiner Form zu zu zu schleifen.
Äh die die Gelegenheit wollen wir euch ähm geben, so wie wir's ja eigentlich mit Corona auch gemacht haben.
Ähm trotzdem ist das natürlich jetzt hier ein anderes Feld, weil wir wissen alle nicht so richtig.
Gut ich meine das wussten wir auch bei bei Corona nicht wer wer weiß schon was die Zukunft bringt aber es ist halt äh auch grade noch eine extrem.
Ja unklare Situation, die mit sehr viel Vorbelastung äh einhergeht, ne.
Und ich ja ich ich denke ich meine wir haben haben eine ganze Menge eingesammelt äh auch an an Informationen und so ein bisschen verdaut die wir dann auch.
Kommentieren wollen und natürlich durchaus jetzt auch sagen, die den Optionsraum ausmachen, was was sind denn jetzt die
möglichen Ergebnisse oder wohin wie wird sich das Ganze
entwickeln oder kann sich das entwickeln in verschiedenen Varianten und für wie wahrscheinlich halten äh wir diese Varianten und,
auch ja welche eventuell auch am Ende welche Lösungsmöglichkeiten äh kann es dann geben je nach
nach Szenario aber auch natürlich eine ganze Menge Kuriositäten und Überraschungen. Es sind ja ganz viele
Dinge plötzlich passiert, die man vorher für undenkbar gehalten hatte
äh so in ganz vielen Ländern. Das hat sich ganz ganz viel gedreht und gekippt und es sind halt ganz viele Firsts gerade
Ähm sodass natürlich auch die Unsicherheit groß ist, weil wenn äh so viele undenkbare Dinge passieren, passieren vielleicht noch mehr undenkbare äh Dinge und das ist natürlich alles äh höchst beunruhigend. Dann ja.
Dann,
wollen wir uns natürlich auch ein bisschen so dann doch der Schuldfrage auch widmen, wobei äh ja äh äh man äh da gucken kann, da kann man halt bis Napoleon
zurückgehen im Grunde genommen.
Napoleon ist schuld.
Na ja, so auf welchem genau, zum Beispiel ist nach äh Napoleon zum Beispiel äh ja, ist jetzt nicht durch die Ukraine, sondern durch Weißrussland gekommen äh so nur für denjenigen, der's der's äh nicht weiß, äh so
Ähm insofern ja können wir Napoleon schon mal abhaken und ähm.
Ja äh mal gucken, dann fragen auch, wie berechtigt sind denn jetzt die russischen Interessen und auch wie kann man das jetzt
ethisch moralisch sehen oder welche welche politischen oder weltanschaulichen Sichten
jetzt auf das Thema und wer hat eigentlich wie viel wer trägt wie viel Verantwortung äh dafür, dass jetzt da Menschen sterben so.
Da das denke ich ist auch auch noch so ein Punkt.
Einschließlich des Westens.
Ja, genau. Was ist was ist unsere Verantwortung äh oder Europas Verantwortung? Amerikas Verantwortung, Russlands Verantwortung im Wesentlichen. Und die Verantwortung der Ukraine.
Ja. Ja. Ähm ich denke.
Vielleicht fangen wir mal an, sagen wer sich da denn jetzt gegenübersteht im Grunde genommen, da noch ein bisschen das mal ein bisschen,
genauer aufzudröseln, weil äh natürlich auf der einen Seite äh klar, Russland.
Ehemalige Weltmacht äh groß flächenmäßig das größte Land der Erde.
Und dann daneben die,
Ukraine so, die so ein bisschen man eher als Zwerg oder oder Winzling
betrachtet im Vergleich zu Russland. Aber wenn man da ein bisschen genauer hinguckt äh so winzig
sie jetzt nun auch nicht. Es ist immerhin ein Land mit 40 Millionen
Einwohnern schon mal ähm nachdem also selbst die Zahl der Einwohner es nicht genau bekannt so zwischen 40 und 44 Millionen wird geschätzt.
Ähm und damit ist sie ungefähr ein Drittel so groß wie Russland.
So, das ist schon mal, das ist schon mal ein Ding, also 40 Millionen oder halb so groß wie Deutschland einwohnermäßig.
Flächenmäßig äh aber gar fast doppelt so groß wie äh die Bundesrepublik.
So also schon äh nicht gerade einen einen Winz legen.
Nee, aber wirtschaftlich nach wie vor.
Wirtschaftlich gesehen, ja wirtschaftlich gesehen, allerdings äh aufgrund,
eben jetzt dieser ja äh ehemals engen Verflechtungen äh mit.
Russland und durch die Abtrennung und dann durch die vielen Jahre Krieg jetzt äh ist, liegt das Land einfach wirtschaftlich am Boden plus die ganzen Korruption. Ähm hat halt
ungefähr einem pro Kopf Durchschnittseinkommen oder Bruttoinlandsprodukt, das ist halb so hoch äh wie das von Russland, also Größenordnungsmäßig irgendwie 10.000 Dollar oder Euro
pro Jahr, je nachdem wie man's nimmt und ungefähr einen Fünftel von dem, was in Deutschland so pro Kopf erwirtschaftet und verdient wird.
Dazu ist äh die Ukraine äh noch der größte Produzent von äh Sonnenblumen.
Produkten oder der größte Ölexporteur der Welt, äh Sonnenblumenöl, ja?
Äh und äh.
Aber auch Sonnenblumensamen ja mit mit Abstand tatsächlich mit irgendwie weiß nicht dreißig, 40 Prozent Weltmarkt äh äh Anteil ähm.
Und äh aber auch äh ja generell Getreide und und Mais und so galt halt auch immer als die Kornkammer.
Der der Sowjetunion äh und ist aber auch äh durchaus eine ganz gut industrialisiertes äh Land. Also ein Großteil der Waffen äh Produktion ähm,
war äh in der Ukraine, also zum Beispiel wurden dort sämtliche Panzermotoren hergestellt äh für für die russischen Kampfpanzer. Äh
was so auch ein bisschen dann reinspielt in das Thema äh äh Krim-Invasion dann war sie natürlich auch äh ja nuklear.
Bewaffnet, hat eine ganze Menge Kernkraftwerk, wie wir wissen, unter anderem das Kernkraftwerk Ternobil, das berüchtigte, steht halt auch in der Ukraine.
Das Herz von den Russen äh besetzt wurde
ja ansonsten kennt man's halt noch äh dadurch, dass es von dort viele günstige IT-Fachkräfte und äh ja
Software schmieden dort sitzen wo man sich Billig-Apps äh entwickeln,
lassen kann. Hat eine ganze Menge Hochschulen äh grade halt äh in karchiv glaube ich äh zehn Hochschulen, was jetzt gerade so unter unter Feuer liegt, unter Beschuss liegt und,
Ja ähm also schon äh einen eigentlich einen einen respektables äh Land auch noch mit Öl und Gas vorkommen. Es spielt,
auch eine Rolle äh so also an sich,
vom von dem her eigentlich einen einen super Land, was man irgendwie eigentlich gerne
so bei sich hatte, was, wo ich mir auch dachte, irgendwie eigentlich wäre das eine super Ergänzung für die EU, ja. Also das hat dieses Land hat einen super
Potential, ja das kann weiß ich nicht. Das also wenn das vernünftig gemanagt äh äh würde so mit dem,
Boden und den Rohstoffen und auch den den Leuten äh äh dort. Also das das das könnte richtig ein ein Paradies.
Seiten eigentlich dieses dieses Land.
Vergessen hast, ist natürlich der Zugang zum Schwarzen Meer. Ne, also das ist natürlich auch äh
jetzt nur militärisch-strategisch, wirtschaftlich natürlich auch nochmal äh ganz interessant.
So eine gewisse Nähe zu Europa oder sagen wir mal zu West zum Westen, ja
zur EU gab es auch schon immer, aber das Land war in sich auch ein wenig gespalten, also während halt
der Westen, dem Westen äh durchaus nahe steht, vor allem auch sehr viel kulturelle Verbindungen zu Polen hat. Das sieht man ja jetzt auch gerade, wie die Polen jetzt äh willig sind. Sehr viele,
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine aufzunehmen, wo sie in der Syrienkrise komplett am Rad gedreht haben.
Äh andererseits hast du natürlich dann im Osten eben besonders in diesen Dornells ähm ja Donald's Donald's.
Sklavische Bereiche. Und natürlich die Krim, äh eine eine sehr viel stärkere russische Prägung hatten, sodass halt auch.
Demokratischen Gesamtausgleich bei den Wahlen es halt immer so war, dass eben.
Region auch erheblich dazu beigetragen haben, dass eben so Russland nahe Gruppierungen, Vertreter und Präsidenten äh.
Dort eher unterstützt wurden, während's halt im Westen genau andersherum aussah.
Man kann sich, man kann sich das ganz gut auch angucken in der Wikipedia äh so äh unter der Seite wie Wahlen in der Ukraine. Da gibt's halt schöne Bilder.
Wo man dann farblich ganz gut sehen kann in welchen Provinzen welche Partei die Mehrheit hatte und da läuft wirklich so schräg diagonal äh wirklich eine eine Linie durchs Land, fast
so wo auf der einen Seite dann eher die sag mal Russlandnahen äh Parteien oder Partei ähm
die Mehrheit hatte und im anderen Bereich eben die andere und es.
War so in etwa auch ausgeglichen so fast fifty fifty, also bei jetzt nationalen Präsidentschaftswahlen konnte da durchaus dann entweder die die,
russlandfreundliche oder mehr die, ich sage mal dem Westen, zugeneigte äh Gruppierung,
Regierungs äh Chef ähm stellen, so dass also ja war halt so halb halbe, halbe
ausgeglichen, sage ich mal, bis aber natürlich Putin dann auf die Idee kam
äh die Krim und die Ostgebiete da rauszunehmen und damit fünf Prozent ungefähr der russisch-freundlichen Wähler aus der
Wählerschaft rauszunehmen, wobei in der wo mit dann in der Westukraine eigentlich auch
kein kein russisch-freundlicher Präsident mehr gewählt werden konnte. Abgesehen davon natürlich von den Ressentiments, äh die das auch bei den Neutralen hervorgerufen hat. Also insofern war halt
diese Invasion der Krim im Nachhinein betrachtet, verhalten völliger Schuss.
Offen. Das war halt äh völlig dämlich, weil so meine These ist, wenn ähm.
Ja Russland einfach nur ein bisschen abgewartet hätte bisschen Geduld gezeigt hätte.
Und ein bisschen weiter ihr mit äh irgendwie Zuckerbrot gewunken hätte, hätte man einfach nur warten müssen, bis sich dann die korrup
Marionetten des Westens, dann die Karten äh legen und dann ja wäre das halt halt umgeschwenkt und.
Noch ein anderes Ding. Ich meine, wir sind jetzt schon ein bisschen bisschen tiefer äh äh drin in der Historie.
Putin hätte also wahrscheinlich nur ein bisschen mehr Geduld äh aufweisen müssen, weil äh klar einen einen Teil des Landes.
Strebte halt kenn Westen oder war Westorientiert, aber am Ende des Tages so richtig haben weder die einen noch die anderen das Land unbedingt besser regiert und.
Ähm letztlich ja Russland hat halt schon vorher doch war halt eigentlich eher nett.
Zur Ukraine, solange die äh jetzt äh da eine Russland
sich Russland freundlich gezeigt hatten, also mit verbilligten Gaslieferungen und wirklich Krediten, also also das die wirtschaftlichen Angebote, die
äh Russland gemacht hatte, war halt monetär. So hat Russland 10 bis 20 Mal so viel Kohle geboten wie die EU. Ja damals
aber ähm der Unterschied war äh der EU war's dann auch relativ egal äh,
äh wie eng denn die Beziehungen zu Russland sind. Also die sagen die,
EU und auch die USA waren da eher, ich sage mal, polygam
eingestellt äh während äh äh Russland halt, aber äh sagen verlangte dafür, dass wenn äh sie halt diesen Freihandel und diese ganzen Subventionen.
In Anspruch nehmen, dass sie dann aber auch exklusiv äh auf der Seite äh von Russland äh sein müssen und eben
keine Freihandelsverträge oder keine äh äh zu große Nähe an die EU oder Annäherung an EU dann mehr wagen dürften. Also Neutralität
war eigentlich damals schon nicht so das das das Ding äh was was Russland
irgendwie haben wollte oder akzeptierte, sondern die wollten ganz klar ähm ja ein Vasallen
jemanden der eng an ihrer Seite steht und
nicht zu nah an den Westen her reicht so ein bisschen der Unterschied äh zwischen,
Ja der der angebotenen Freundschaft vom Westen und der angebotenen äh äh Freundschaft vom Osten.
Weil wie sich jetzt auch zeigt, Putins äh planen eigentlich äh sagt, dass er die Ukraine dann doch eher als Teil eines eines Großrusslands versteht, so wie auch Weißrussland.
Und ähm vielleicht nicht unbedingt wieder äh sowjetische Zustände
ähm haben möchte, aber doch zumindest eben diese Gebietsansprüche hat und eben da so ein so ein so ein großrussischen Traum verfolgt, der vielleicht mehr mit der Zarenzeit davor zu tun hat äh in seinem Gehabe als vielleicht jetzt mit der UDSSR.
Ja, also bei den genau bei den Vermutungen jetzt, okay, was ist jetzt schon da sind und sagen, was sind denn eigentlich jetzt die,
potenziellen Ziele oder was was ist denn jetzt das Ziel von von Russland? Hm na jetzt sagen wir mal äh was ist der Plan und oder was war der Plan?
Und äh da hatte ich sogar auch im Vorfeld äh jetzt äh so mir verschiedene Gedanken gemacht beziehungsweise einiges gehört, was den der Plan,
sein könnte und das eine ist, wie du richtig sagst, die gesamte Ukraine wieder, ich sage mal Heim ins Russische Reich oder in die russische Föderation äh hinein,
zu holen. Ähm aber äh.
Das ist äh natürlich eher ein ein Plan, der nicht so nicht so superleicht oder super realistisch äh ist und deswegen,
war die Vermutung ähm dass eigentlich das Ziel sein könnte ähm die Ukraine dadurch zu neutralisieren, indem man sie in mehrere Teile auf,
splittet einige Teile dann direkt äh Russland zuschlägt beziehungsweise äh ja einige Teile der Ukraine
zu Vasallen macht und dann so eine Restukraine hat, die aber dann so schwach auch äh ist,
äh und so kaputt äh dass sie halt ähm,
auch auf Russland angewiesen ist und äh keine Gefahr oder keine Bedrohung äh mehr darstellt, also quasi eine
zwangsdemilitarisierte Ukraine, die dann dauerhaft vielleicht mit einem kleinen Kontingent
ja von von befreundeten Truppen äh dann äh besetzt ist die die Ordnung.
Aufrechterhalten, so wie,
das dann vielleicht früher aus dem Ostblock oder aus der DDR kannten oder auch äh umgekehrt äh äh Westdeutschland halt war ja nun auch ähm so letztlich ein besetzter.
Äh so will Vasallenstaat äh wobei äh die die Leine natürlich die jetzt die Westalliierten jetzt der Bundesrepublik gegeben haben, war doch sehr lang.
Also ähm das war sehr gemütlich äh eigentlich von den Alliierten besetzt zu sein. Merkte man nicht wirklich viel von.
Aber
Ja, äh aber umgekehrt ja, glaube ich, so was hatte sich dann äh ähm ich Putin jetzt vorgestellt. Also im Grunde genommen die Zeit ein bisschen zurückzudrehen, so auf neunzehnhundertfünfundsiebzig wieder. Das war.
Dann so so sein Ziel. Aber äh ja, wie wir wie wie sich dann ganz schnell raus.
Gestellt hat, äh hat er sich dann entscheidend verrechnet. So ähm weil.
Dass das war dann und es war auch gar nicht ich meine es war auch gar nicht so dumm, also.
Seine seine Annahmen, äh die er äh die er gemacht hat grundsätzlich, weil ähm,
Seine Marionetten äh.
Die in in der Ukraine kaum wurd's brenzlig ähm haben die sich in den Hubschrauber gesetzt und sind los und,
eine Vermutung ist auch, dass der amerikanische Abzug auf aus Afghanistan ihn,
da beflügelt haben könnte, als er dann gesehen hat, äh wie dann die ja.
Vasallen äh Regierung oder Marionettenregierung der Amerikaner in Afghanistan äh ähm ja sich sich auch äh ja die Hubschrauber mit Bargeld vollge
hat und sie ausm Staub gemacht hat, bevor da überhaupt nur ein Schussgefall. Also als als die Taliban da nur an der an der Grenze von Kabul waren, war der schon weg. So, deswegen war jetzt die Annahme wenn er jetzt da Militär auffährt in Richtung Kiew,
ist halt genauso laufen wird und äh deswegen haben die Amerikaner ja auch ähm
ähm dann Selenski, ja haben ihm ja auch angeboten, ihn ihn auszufliegen, aber was dann passierte äh war halt dann
mal wieder äh ja äh also die Welt ist ist nicht mehr dieselbe und Selenski war offensichtlich nun auch jetzt kein Vasall.
Der Amerikaner weil Vasallen machen sowas nicht und stellen sich dann hin.
Äh äh bringen dann auch noch so epische Sprüche äh wie äh ja ich brauche ich brauche Munition und keine Mitfahrgelegenheit so was sicherlich einer der
epischsten Sprüche äh jemals ist, die äh die irgendwie einen.
So einer Situation.
In einer solchen Situation abgegeben hat so und eigentlich war.
War das, dass das Ding, was wie ich glaube, äh dann seine gesamten Pläne und äh seine gesamte Planung äh einfach äh ja äh zertrümmert äh hat.
Zerlegt hat. Wir wir sollten an der Stelle glaube ich dann mal ähm auch auf den anderen Protagonisten eingehen. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt über Putin nicht so viel gesprochen, aber das Russland der letzten 30 Jahre.
Ist es schon so viel oder verrechnen die mich gerade? Der ist schon seit 30 Jahren dabei, ne? Ähm.
Mehr mehr ja ja ja ja. Wer Putin ist da jetzt seit 22 Jahren dabei genau seit der abgelöst hat vor.
Ja genau, äh okay hat eben grad ein schlechtes Gefühl, dass ich 30 Jahre gesagt habe. Aber die letzten 20 Jahre beim in Russland waren Putins Russland und er war ja von Anfang an.
Für uns ein Mysterium. Ich fand das so lustig, dass jetzt in den letzten Wochen, Monaten.
Irgendwann irgendwo sah ich dann so eine Schlagzeile und war sie sogar beim Spiel und ich weiß es jetzt nicht. Irgendwo stand so wer ist Putin?
Ja?
Mhm.
Das war dieses Jahr. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht mehr genau, welche Quelle das war. Was ich aber genau wusste ist, dass als er vor 20 Jahren dann die Macht kam.
Das war der Spiegel-Titel.
Weil ihn kannte ja keiner. Er war ja irgendwie so ein äh Mitarbeiter beim Geheimdienst, beim KGB.
In Sankt Petersburg und das ist so ein bisschen so seine Heimat auch. Er ist halt einfach aus dem Apparat und,
es gab dieses ganze Hin und Her. Wer soll jetzt irgendwie Russland führen und auf einmal kam aus der dritten Reihe irgendwie dieser Typ und stellte sich in die in die in die äh auf den Präsidentenposten und keiner hatte ihn aufm Zettel.
Na ja, also im Grunde.
Frage natürlich berechtigt berechtigt, ne? Wer er denn nun sei und ich habe so den Eindruck, 20 Jahre später äh wissen's halt irgendwie immer alle noch nicht.
Ja er hat ich äh äh.
Äh war dann auch durchaus derjenige, der ihn, wie es schön heißt, enthorst äh hat, also schon gesagt hat, hier.
Wählt den Mann. Ähm und Jels hin äh war ja äh tatsächlich ich dachte ja immer Gorbatschow
äh wäre sozusagen der unbeliebteste Präsident äh gewesen. Wobei gut, das war Sowjetunion, aber ähm ja weil er weil jetzt sich
äh ähm irgendwie für den Zerfall äh der Sowjetunion äh ich ich immer verantwortlich gemacht habe, wobei auch das.
Er nicht wirklich äh äh war, sondern da gehörten, dass das waren halt äh unter anderem eben,
Jel ziehen und äh dann äh halt auch die ukrainischen und weißrussischen und.
Union war vor allem für den Zerfall der Sowjetunion verantwortlich würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, ja, ja, aber beziehungsweise dann dann schon die, die damals die äh äh Provinzchefs
äh von Ukraine, Weißrussland und was noch, die haben sich dann diesen Geheimtreffen getroffen und dann einfach mal beschlossen äh wir wir lösen äh dass das Ganze jetzt auf
Und äh Jelzi äh kann auch sagen, Jelsin war.
Äh äh vom Westen überzeugt,
manche sagen, er war eine westliche Marionette, aber jetzt sind's Überzeugung war, wir müssen,
so werden wie der Westen
weil die sind uns in allem so voraus, äh so, wir sind so hinterher, wir müssen uns eigentlich bei dem alle bei denen alles abgucken und eigentlich Russland auch in ein westliches
Land transformieren, so das war davon war er äh zutiefst überzeugt. Und.
Hat dann dementsprechend auch äh so ja alle möglichen Reformen äh durchgeführt äh ja viele staatseigene Betriebe geschlossen.
Privatisiert ähm hm damit die Oligarchen.
Aufgebaut im Rahmen dieser Privatisierungs äh Aktion, aber
auch eine ganze Menge äh Reformen ja Kapitalmarkt äh eingeführt und also äh schon wenn man genau hinguckt ist in der jetzigen Zeit äh
eine Menge passiert, eine eine einiges andere Formen äh passiert, äh dass äh.
Aber dann erst natürlich solche Sachen funktionieren dann erst später, äh aber erstmal war das natürlich ein Schock äh Plus,
dass dann.
Der Ölpreis auch äh in den in den Keller ging, also fast während der gesamten Yelsin-Zeit war halt der Ölpreis ziemlich niedrig, das heißt finanziell war der Spielraum auch sehr sehr gering. Was dazu führte
das Yelsin dann mit einer Zustimmung von 6 Prozent aus dem Amt ging, ja.
Also es war der ja äh unwirklich unbeliebteste Präsident aller Zeiten.
Dazu.
Und als Putin? Ja gut, das aber als Putin äh dann übernahm, hat der es ganz ganz schnell geschafft.
Ja für sehr sehr viel Zustimmung zu sorgen, indem er so ein paar Dinge halt gestoppt und zurückgedreht hat auch
und hatte dann plötzlich Zustimmungsraten äh erstmal von sechzig, 70 gingen bis 90 Prozent rauf.
Und seitdem schwanken sagen die die die Zustimmung für Putin in Russland so zwischen 65 und 90
Prozent und für wenn wenn's und als es auf 65 runter war beim letzten Mal äh hat er halt die Krim-Invasion gemacht. Woraufhin das dann spontan auf neunzig Prozent äh wieder hoch ging.
Die Zustimmung und also so viel ähm ja äh Zustimmung findet man im im westlichen Demokratien selten.
Ja, dass jemand irgendwie 90 Prozent des des nur, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht in Kriegszeiten oder wenn jemand richtig gut performt. Also ja, nee, also neunzig Prozent kommt man.
Irgendwie kaum ran. Also es ist ist schon äh dann ein Phänomen
und äh Putin im Gegensatz zu Yalcin hielt jetzt
nicht so viel von Demokratie und und und dem Westen. So das war ihm
ihm alles nix. Also er äh ist so eher der Meinung, das sind halt alles irgendwie ja
sind intrigant und und und quatschen einfach ihm zu viel und äh ja sind ihm auch sonst einfach
hochgradig äh suspekt so. Das sind halt alles für ihn.
Für für Putin im Gegensatz zu Yalcin war der Westen jetzt kein Vorbild äh nachdem man.
Ähm Russland jetzt gestalten sollte oder könnte und auch Demokratie hält er im Grunde genommen,
für eine Showveranstaltung ähm so die Leute wissen nicht, äh also Leute Putin ist eher der Meinung, die Leute haben eh keine Ahnung was gut für sie ist.
Und.
In gewisser Hinsicht auch.
Ja, hierher.
Alternative auch nicht unbedingt besser ist.
Nee, nee und man muss auch sagen, er hat äh durchaus
äh ja eine Reihe von von Erfolgen erzielt, das Land stabilisiert durchaus auch wirtschaftlich und in,
bestimmten Bereichen eben auch entwickelt. Vielleicht ein Teil davon äh ist
im Grunde genommen Yal Shines äh äh Dienst, weil der so äh die die unbeliebten Einschnitte gemacht hat und und und
Putin konnte dann auch so ein bisschen ja dann dann ernten letztlich und dann erholte sich dann irgendwann auch der Ölpreis und äh ja ähm alles wurde besser und ähm,
man hat halt Putin dafür äh dann gedankt, obwohl er
gar nicht genau hinguckt, wahrscheinlich einfach vor allem Glück hatte.
Äh allerdings, was man sagen muss, er ist halt auch ein er ist ein guter Politiker und Taktiker und was was er gemacht hat, ist, dass er halt die Oligarchen.
Eingenortet hat sie unter sich äh äh gebracht hat während es sonst so war, dass,
ja meistens die Oligarchen sich aussuchten ähm wer Präsident wird, äh hat er
das Ganze umgekehrt und hat halt die Oligarchen im Prinzip äh ja unter seine Knute gebracht und gesagt okay also entweder ihr macht hier jetzt mit und tut was ich sage
oder äh ihr kommt in den Knast, so wie das nicht, Berischsowski oder so. Also wer wer da nicht mit zog, äh wurde halt dann äh kalt gestellt, enteignet, in den Knast gestellt.
Genau, also er hat ausgesucht, wer unter ihm Oli Garch sein darf.
Und äh er ist sicherlich irgendwie äh mit in diesem Geldspiel auch dabei. Ihm geht's nicht schlecht. Ähm.
Aber was ihn halt am Ende wirklich äh treibt, das äh bleibt einem dann doch irgendwie ein Rätsel, aber wenn er halt glaube ich einmal auf dieser Diktatornummer festhängst und ich finde King Health, dann dann gibt's auch.
Ja, ich.
Ich glaube, äh ist einfach der Meinung, er ist der Einzige, der das äh irgendwie vernünftig auf die Reihe äh kriegt und tut das schon äh denke ich, äh ja für für Russland und für das russische
Volk, also das ist, denke ich, was er sich so einredet, dass äh ja
Außer ihm, also wenn er nicht da ist oder da wäre, dann wäre es alles ganz schlimm.
Und rechnet sich quasi die ganzen Erfolge, die tatsächlich passiert sind dann zu seiner Zeit führt er halt allein auf sich zurück oder in erster Linie auf sich zurück. Aber wenn man dann bisschen genauer hinschaut, gerade in den letzten fünf Jahren.
Äh oder zehn Jahren stellt man fest, da ist nicht alles Gold, was glänzt und insbesondere seine ja, ich nenn's mal Autonomie,
Politik äh erinnert mich so ein bisschen auch an die Nazis und an an Hitler auch gesagt hatten, wir müssen autark werden, wir müssen unabhängig werden äh vom vom Rest
äh der Welt und das ist halt äh ja,
ein äh Katastrophenrezept, weil wir weil heute ist es noch mehr äh so als als damals. Du kannst als Land
nicht autark leben, beziehungsweise wenn, dann hast du halt bist du so was wie Nordkorea.
Ja und selbst Nordkorea schafft es nicht autark äh zu sein, weil es es fehlt dir dann an bestimmten Dingen. Du kannst nicht alles, äh was so ein modernes Industrieland
braucht in deinem Land herstellen, egal wie groß es ist. Ist ja auch Amerika kann das nicht.
Und äh deswegen du brauchst halt große internationale Arbeitsteilungen und da werden wir glaube ich gleich noch bei dem Thema Sanktionen äh kommen. Wie äh krass das ist und wie.
Trotz aller Autarkie-Bestrebungen in den letzten Jahren, wie sehr äh oder wie wie wenig die gefruchtet haben etwa beim Thema Chip-Produktion oder beim Thema Raumfahrt,
aber dazu später.
Den anderen äh Protagonisten auch nochmal beleuchten.
Sielensky.
Der aktuelle Präsident der Ukraine. Das ist ja so ein Typ ganz nach meinem Geschmack. Also,
Die Story also äh vorhin flog so ein Tweet an mir vorbei. Er meinte so, ja also äh.
Wenn wenn jemand irgendwie die Story äh so äh Hollywoodangeboten hätte, das das das hätte hätte einfach das Drehbuch hätte einfach keiner genommen. Das das wäre einfach alles zu verrückt irgendwie so.
Mit Weltkrieg und dann irgendwie auf der einen Seite Diktator oder auf der anderen Seite so ein ehemaliger Schauspieler, der irgendwie Präsidenten in der Fernsehserie gespielt hat. Woraufhin,
dann irgendwann auf die Idee kam, naja wenn die anderen irgendwie alle so scheiße sind, dann stelle ich mich halt einfach zum Präsidenten. Ich habe das ja schon mal als Schauspieler gemacht. Das kann ja so schwer nicht sein. Und dann wird er auch noch gewählt.
Ist er jetzt irgendwie in dieser Situation auf einmal so der der die zentrale Projektionsfigur
gesamten Konflikts und ist dabei aber auch noch auf eine gewisse Art und Weise brilliant sowohl was jetzt
seine Zeit vorher betrifft, so in der man halt einfach wirklich ein ordentlicher Komiker und äh ausgesprochen guter Tänzer war, aber eben jetzt auch einfach eine Seriösität.
Ähm an den Tag legt ähm mit der wenige wohl auch in der Ukraine so gerechnet haben oder auch international es dadurch auch schafft eine Aufmerksamkeit für diesen Konflikt.
Noch zu erhöhen, der euer ohnehin schon relativ hoch ist, weil er diese Standfestigkeit.
Quasi die Ukraine Bevölkerung jetzt.
Benötigt auch und auch hat, äh wie es den anscheinend macht in der Unternachform auch nach außen abstrahlt und so ein bisschen so dieses Zentrum, das das Nicht-Aufgebens ist.
Also es spielt da halt spielen halt viele interessante äh Dinge rein. Ich meine, er kommt ja aus einem jüdischen Elternhaus.
Nie religiös, weil zu Sowjetzeiten war halt Religionsausübung äh sowieso äh nicht so nicht so angesagt und und Juden in Russland
war jetzt auch immer so ein nicht so gerade äh ähm äh,
Ja äh das das harmonischste äh oder willkommenste Verhältnis und dann ähm so zu Sowjetzeiten äh haben die
waren quasi auch eine Nische oft in der Gesellschaft gefunden so als als Wissenschaftler, Professoren, Lehrer so, das war dann.
Äh dann quasi das das das Ding und äh ja und bei
Selensky, was auch interessant ist, wie gesagt, wird jetzt nie groß. Jetzt wird die jüdische Kultur unbedingt zelebriert, aber ähm tatsächlich ist die Ukraine auch äh sowohl in Europa jetzt
äh auch zu einem Land geworden äh nach der Auflösung der Sowjetunion, wo halt dann doch sehr viel jüdisches
äh Leben äh wieder äh wieder erwachsen ist, weshalb dann auch Israel äh sagen da sehr viel Unterstützung auch geliefert.
Dem dem Silinsky und äh auch
ja Netanjahu da öfter zu Besuch war und äh also Israel äh ist vermutlich eines der ähm einer der größten auch heimlichen äh Ukraine äh Unterstützer oder oder
oder Helfer, ähm wenn man so will und ähm ja, dann dann haben wir auch noch äh,
hattest du ja schon erwähnt, also es lohnt sich äh auch also seine seine Tanzeinlagen dabei Let's Dance, äh was er da gewonnen hat, wo er da wirklich in epischen Kostümen
einfach großartige äh Tänze äh macht, wo ich mir dann auch vorstellen kann, dass das alles überhaupt nicht nach Putins Geschmack,
beziehungsweise des Putin ihn keine für irgendeine Schwuchtel hält und überhaupt,
ernst nimmt allein wegen der wegen der Kostüme. Auch sehr episch äh so sein ja Klavierkonzert für vier Penisse äh.
Es es ist wirklich auch zu dem dem Flachwitz.
Überhaupt gar keine Berührungsprobleme, der stellt sich hin und macht sich einfach zum äh zum Kasper, ne? Aber im besten Sinne des Wortes. Also das ist schon wirklich so ein so ein echter Humorist und jemand, der,
äh in der Lage ist sich selber nicht ausreichend ernst zu nehmen und sich damit in gewisser Hinsicht aber auch den Respekt äh erst richtig erarbeitet.
Jetzt die Fernsehserie tatsächlich Dina des Volkes äh so die auch großartig ist. Also ich habe jetzt so die von der ersten Staffel irgendwie die Hälfte glaube ich gesehen und.
So die ersten drei Episoden habe ich jetzt glaube ich durch.
Ich kann's äh wirklich nur empfehlen, weil auch so ein bisschen, man lernt sehr viel über die Ukraine und auch wenn vieles äh so bisschen over the top
ist. So es hat alles einen wahren Kern. Dann können sie wirklich die die Korruption und die
Obrigkeitshörigkeit und wie und die Steuermoral und äh ja das ist es ist also alles schon nicht nicht irgendwie frei erfunden, sondern das ist äh ja äh schon auch
auf den Punkt gebracht. So und,
Er spielt halt äh dort in dieser äh äh Serie Diener des Volkes, spielt er halt einen Präsidenten äh.
Der dann äh ein ein Lehrer, der dann aufgrund.
Eines äh Videos, wo er wo er sich aufregt über die über die Regierung, was ein Schüler aufnimmt, dass dann viral geht und.
Die ähm ja und äh die Schüler sammeln dann im Internet
Crowdfunding die Anmeldegebühr um für den um als Präsident zu kandidieren und äh
drücken ihm das Geld in die Hand und stellen ihnen vor die Wahl. Also macht damit was du willst so. Haus aufn Kopf oder melde dich an für die Wahl und er wird dann halt auch in dem in der Serie wird er dann auch gewählt.
Und äh spielt dann halt äh dort so einen Präsidenten, der dann relativ unbeleckt,
ahnungslos natürlich in alle möglichen Fallen äh läuft, aber eben,
idealistisch und mit dem Herz am äh rechten Fleck und auch mit einem gewissen äh Witz und äh ja, es ist dann schafft sich irgendwie dadurch zu lavieren und allen möglichen,
in einer wirklich unmöglichen Situation dann
dann trotzdem irgendwie die Dinge langsam zum Besseren bewegen zu können, wobei sich dann sag mal, Erfolge und Katastrophen so ablösen, wie wie im richtigen Leben so und das ist deswegen so relevant auch diese Serie, weil
Ähm äh er ist dann nämlich nachdem diese Serie, die sehr erfolgreich war, auch hohe Produktion Quality würde ich sagen. Äh ähm,
Ist er unter dem Namen der Serie, also auch Diener des Volkes ist ja dann angetreten tatsächlich in Realität. Äh.
Auch äh also voll unterstützt äh von dem Oligarchen, dem auch der Fernsehsender geirrte, wo diese Serie gelaufen ist. Ähm.
Äh der hat im Übrigen auch ja aus dem Land fliehen musste, weil er irgendwie auch äh äh Gelder veruntreut hatte und so und.
Aber äh als als äh Silenski dann wirklich gewählt wurde, also.
Auch gesagt, na ja, die Leute haben jetzt nicht wirklich mich als Schauspieler gewählt, sondern sie haben diesen Präsidenten gewählt, den ich dort gespielt habe,
und deswegen möchte ich jetzt auch in der Realität.
Dieser Präsident sein, den die Leute dort gewählt haben. Das heißt, sie hat halt versucht, lang seine Präsidentschaft oder seine Rolle als Politiker
tatsächlich möglichst genau an die Rolle dieses Präsidenten
anzupassen und es ist auch wirklich es gibt äh so viele Parallelen äh dann und eigentlich
erinnerte mich das Ganze dann auch so ein bisschen hier an die Wahl der Piraten oder an andere Dinge, wo mir auch völlig
unbeleckt äh und ahnungslos und naiv plötzlich in ein politisches Establishment ähm hineingestolpert sind, sodass sich
sagen das auch ganz gut nachvollziehen.
Kann, ja? Also es ist eben auch so ein so eine Nummer oder in Tschechien ist ja auch jetzt die Piratenpartei äh äußerst erfolgreich und äh ja also
Auch die die Geschichte somit, dass man da erstmal reingeht und erstmal voll auf die Fresse kriegt und äh äh hinfällt und dann aber ja hoffentlich genug Zeit hat äh genug dazu zu lernen, bevor man dann abserviert wird.
Uns ist es halt nicht gelungen, so richtig mit den Piraten, aber in anderen
also in Deutschland, aber in anderen äh Teilen der Welt klappt das dann schon oder bisschen wie auch in Island. Äh der dann da gewählt wurde nach der
nach der Krise auch so ein so ein Komiker ähm der dann zum Bürgermeister wurde.
War im Prinzip so ein bisschen die Vorlage wahrscheinlich, aber ich meine die die Traute musste natürlich dann auch erstmal haben so, ne und ja
und es ist halt seine Beliebtheit war dann aber eben wie das eben so ist, wenn man erstmal an den Hebeln äh sitzt. Du kannst es nicht allen recht machen und es ging natürlich auch nur begrenzt voran und er hatte
den Krieg im äh im im Donetsch im den Krieg im Donbass Trial.
Ganze Zeit durcheinander. Donbass nennt man die Region Donald und sind die die Bezirksgebiete da, die Religionsgebiete, die Länder.
Also im Don war's den Krieg äh in irgendeiner Form zu einer Lösung zu finden. Jetzt wissen wir auch irgendwie, warum das nicht geklappt hat, weil Putin da gar kein Interesse daran hat äh da in irgendeiner Form eine Lösung zu finden. Das ging nie
nie um irgendein Problem, sondern es ging nur dadrum, diese Unruhe die ganze Zeit
Laufen zu halten, um irgendwie die Ukraine unattraktiv zu machen für den Westen und die Strategie ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch aufgegangen, weil es wurde nicht äh,
so eingebunden und aufgenommen oder in die EU eingeladen. Wie äh die Ukraine das vielleicht selber gerne äh gehabt hätte. Und dieses ewige Hin und Her mit dem dem dem dem korrupten Präsidenten.
Äh klar, das hat natürlich auch viele abgeschreckt.
Ja und äh und äh als Selenski dann loslegte, befand er sich halt in in einer genauso unmöglichen Situation wie in der Serie. Also erstens,
politisch nicht wirklich Ahnung ja äh keine Hausmacht äh kaum Connections äh so
äh dann nur ein Oligarchen auf seiner Seite und zehn Oligarchen gegen sich äh so dann noch der vorherige Präsident äh der äh der da nicht so begeistert.
Drüber war äh genau der also äh Plus äh dann äh ja die die,
Die Ultrarechten, äh die die Zoff machten
ähm bis hin zu na ja Mordanschlägen auf ihm so. Also die die komplette Packung und eigentlich eine komplett,
hoffnungslose Situation. Also wer ihn da gesehen hat, hat ihm eigentlich nicht mehr als ein Jahr gegeben äh bevor äh er äh äh sich die Karten legt und äh irgendwie.
Dazu noch Trump im.
Ja ja genau.
Weißen Haus, der ihn äh sozusagen mit seinen Ukraine Connections eigentlich auch nur äh missbraucht hat und äh der lange Arm die fünfte Kolonne Putin.
Genau und.
Und dann noch genau und dann noch Trump und Putin im im im Nacken so. Also neben den ganzen innenpolitischen Problemen so eigentlich nur ein Wunder.
Dass er überhaupt so lange durchgehalten hat und sich dann ausgerechnet äh äh als äh die
figur erwiesen hat äh ja die ähm Putin so komplett den Plan verhagelt hat durch äh ja,
ein paar Sätze, die er geäußert hat und durch seine Entscheidung zu sagen, wir bleiben, wir kämpfen so.
Ja, damit damit wären wir glaube ich beim Kriegsgeschehen als solchen, das können wir jetzt nicht in allen Details,
nacherzählen, aber vielleicht grob müssen wir mal so ein bisschen einfangen, was aus unserer Perspektive so jetzt ähm im Wesentlichen.
Passiert ist. Wir haben's ja jetzt schon zwei-, dreimal angedeutet. Ihr werdet's ja auch alle gehört haben, aber das ist jetzt so ein bisschen auch Teil äh unserer Einsortierung hier, um um einfach mal eine Grundlage zu haben für für eine weitere Betrachtung. Also.
Über längeren Zeitraum, Wochen, Monate haben die Russen.
An verschiedensten Stellen rund um die an Ukraine herum in ihrem eigenen Land wie aber auch in Weißrussland Kräfte zusammengezogen in der Größenordnung von ungefähr 15.000 Soldaten und na ja tonnenweise Panzer.
Raketenwerfergerät, Infrastruktur, Tanklaster, was weiß ich, halt Militärkram. Das fiel natürlich auf,
Wir hatten jetzt wochenlang diese ganze Debatte mit was macht ihr denn da eigentlich? Natürlich haben die irgendwas erzählt von Manöver und so. Zumindest haben sie aus ihren eigenen Soldaten erzählt.
Und ja die USA waren irgendwie diejenigen, die glaube ich so am klarsten dann auch kommuniziert haben und das schon so eine Woche vorher so ja äh alles klar, die greifen jetzt irgendwie an,
und zwar dann und dann.
Die Pläne sind natürlich geleakt, weil wenn du so einen großen Einsatz
äh hast, äh sind da einfach zu viel Leute involviert und das ist halt ein super komplexer Plan
Muss man sich vorstellen, normalerweise, also ich habe halt
die die entsprechenden Pläne äh für äh der Sat äh Storm äh habe ich äh mal gesehen. Das sind
halt ja PDFs tausende von Seiten wie so ein.
Plan im Grunde genommen, wo für jede Einheit festgelegt ist, das Einsatzgebiet wann sie wo äh sein dürfen, welche äh Frequenzen und Rufzeichen äh sie verwenden und äh von wem sie versorgt werden und so. Aber das Wichtigste
eigentlich an der ganzen Geschichte ist, ähm dass äh die Truppen sich halbwegs an den an den Plan,
halten, äh weil oft gerade wenn so Artillerie äh Kämpfe oder mit mit Panzern.
Kannst du die oft auf die Entfernung
von mehreren Kilometern bis zu, weiß ich nicht, fünf, zehn Kilometern äh oder mit Raketen, die russischen Raketen fliegen bis zu 40 Kilometer weit, mit denen sie da diese Mehrfachraketenwerfer, die sie wie sie haben.
Ja also du siehst nicht wirklich genau auf wen du schießt, wenn da siehst halt nur da Fahrzeuge oder eine eine Kolonne und äh je nachdem äh ja,
ähm entscheidest du, ob du schießt äh anhand dessen, ob da eigene Truppen sein dürfen laut Plan oder nicht.
Und äh wenn da keine sein sollten, dann können's sich's nur um Feinde handeln und wenn das aber,
offen Ruder läuft, dann äh kommt's halt dann eben auch zu,
Ja äh zum Beschuss eigener Kräfte, dass es den Amerikanern auch im Golfkrieg passiert, wo sie dann fünfmal äh oder zehnmal so viel Verluste hatten äh durch Friendly Fire.
Und das wird den Russen jetzt teilweise auch nicht anders gehen. Wobei ähm Russen eigentlich ähm.
Auch äh ja so eine sehr einfache Taktik verfolgen oder.
Nicht anders können, die äh dann im amerikanischen Militär äh Jargon als IFR bezeichnet wird. I follow road ähm
und dann halt jetzt zu diesem 60 Kilometer Stau äh vor Kiew geführt hat äh so der. Äh wobei halt
wenn du
Ich meine Medien wurde es mal dargestellt, oh riesen Konvoi irgendwie auf dem Weg äh nach Kiew aber er war nicht wirklich aufm Weg, sondern die standen da halt im Stau. Mehr oder weniger.
Ein Parkplatz und das ist halt blöd, wenn deine Kräfte im Stau stehen.
Stehen da halt Vorräte, die eigentlich woanders gebraucht werden und Munition die woanders gebraucht wird und äh weil's da auch kalt ist, lassen die Leute die Motoren laufen und die Leute müssen halt essen und das ist halt nicht gut.
Plus, dass Sie im Grunde genommen ja schön Sitting Dax äh sind und für und wenn,
Außerdem dann irgendwo mal ein paar eine eine Brücke oder einen einen in einem kleinen Angriff dann ein paar Fahrzeuge erstmal äh in Brand geschossen werden, dann geht's halt auch erstmal nicht mehr nicht mehr weiter und.
Äh ich habe also sowohl eine NATO äh einen amerikanischen General und auch einem Bundeswehrgeneral als die erzählten habe ich das Gefühl den.
Fast in den Fingern. Die würden so gerne da reingehen, weil ja das Gefühl haben, oh mein Gott, was sind das für Amateure? Gib uns zwei, drei Tage und irgendwie ein, zwei Flugzeugträger und wir machen die alle,
ja das ist so ein bisschen die Einschätzung gerade äh von,
von amerikanischer Seite. Klar, wenn jetzt nicht die atomare Bedrohung und so wäre aber rein konventionell, was die, was die Russen äh äh da da machen, ist halt,
äh ja ähm nicht also militärisch nicht besonders,
professionell äh so. Aber gut, müsste es eigentlich auch nicht sein, äh wenn man denn die große Übermacht hätte. Nur.
Da kommen wir jetzt noch zum zum nächsten Punkt. Nämlich die die Zahlen. So, wer hat eigentlich wer ist eigentlich jetzt.
So Truppen und und equipmentmäßig und so wie stark und,
Ich habe dann versucht mal rauszufinden, okay wie viel Soldaten und Panzer haben, denn die Ukrainer überhaupt.
Da finden sich also jede alle Quellen widersprechen sich,
komplett oder oder liefern äh total verschiedene Zahlen, aber ähm so was sicher ist, also Russland scheint so,
um die 200.000 Soldaten versammelt zu haben,
bisher um die Ukraine rum von denen mittlerweile 80 Prozent auch im Einsatz sind, also über die über die Grenze äh sind so nach dem was ich weiß.
Gehört habe.
Während die Ukraine mindestens 400.000 Soldaten hat. Möglicherweise auch bis zu 1,1 Millionen. So,
irgendwo dazwischen äh äh äh liegt das äh so und ähm außerdem hat die Ukraine.
Nach einer Quelle achthundert,
Kampfpanzer nach anderen Quellen bis zu 3000 Kampfpanzer. Ähm,
dann nach anderen Quellen 12.000 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge, nach anderen Quellen bis zu 30.000 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge.
Plus aber auch noch sieben Millionen Leute die äh als fit for Military Service äh gelten.
Ähm so im Alter von sechzehn bis bis neunundvierzig und alleine vierhundertsiebzigtausend
so ist ist so ein Jahrgang groß, das heißt sie könnten eigentlich äh ähm ja vierhundertsiebzig ungefähr eine halbe Million Leute pro Jahrgang da äh da einziehen. Also,
nichts Genaues weiß man nicht aber ähm.
Ja äh aber es sind viele. Also Soldaten, an Soldaten haben die die Ukrainer viele sogar wahrscheinlich ähm ja äh während die russische Armee ähm.
Hat äh wohl so achthundert, 900.000 aktive Soldaten.
Wovon aber ein Drittel Wehrpflichtige sind, die eigentlich nach Gesetz
äh äh gar nicht äh nur im Inland eingesetzt werden dürfen. Der Rest sind Berufs- und Zeitsoldaten und die meisten, die da jetzt einmarschieren dürften, äh dürfte es sich um Zeitsoldaten äh handeln und um Reservisten.
Äh so. Und äh wie gesagt, aber sie haben halt ungefähr 200.000 jetzt dort versammelt, äh aber selbst wenn sie,
gesamt Russland äh so äh alles Aktive Personal, was sie haben.
Kämen die Russen maximal auf 600.000 ohne Reservisten, wobei sie jetzt schon jede Menge auch Reservisten eben.
Äh haben, ähm aber rein.
Man powermäßig äh erstmal ähm ham die Russen äh da äh sind da deutlich unterlegen, zumal du als Angreifer
Auch nochmal äh stärker sein musst, weil du je nach je nach Terrain einen Defensivvorteil von 3 zu
eins in manchen also in im im ja im im Häuserkampf oder so eher besser 5 zu eins.
Äh hast, um da äh äh wirklich entscheidend,
voranzukommen und im Moment sieht es eher so aus, als würden die Ukrainer sozusagen eher eine Überlegenheit äh Manpower mäßig von mindestens drei zu eins äh haben. So
ähm insofern ist.
Worauf basierst du das? Ich meine die ganze Informations äh Lage ist natürlich extrem äh prekär, ne.
Na ja, ich habe ich habe äh gesagt, ich habe da fünf verschiedene Quellen äh
konsultiert, was so die militärische Stärke angeht, was so im Wesentlichen in der Presse veröffentlicht wurde, was in Wikipedia äh steht und äh ja, eine Reihe von von von Presseberichten
und äh wie gesagt, die passen alle nicht nicht wirklich zusammen, aber ähm ja,
größenordnungsmäßig jedenfalls was Manpower angeht scheint.
Das relativ klar zu sein, dass das die Ukrainer äh3 bis fünfmal so viele Soldaten zur Verfügung haben äh wie die Russen derzeit um die Ukraine versammelt.
Haben, ja? Und wenn man dann noch noch rechnet, ach so, was dann auch noch dazukommt, ist, dass man in der Ukraine schon seit Jahren im Prinzip jeder auch Waffen einfach kaufen konnte.
Einfach in den Laden gehen und äh weil da war Krieg äh und da
ja haben sich halt viele Leute auch einfach so bewaffnet, wurden jetzt nicht erst noch Waffen ausgehändigt, sondern wer ein bisschen Kohl hatte oder aufm Land lebte, der hat in der Ukraine auch auch eine Schusswaffe. So das das
äh ja und von daher habe ich mich dann gefragt, äh wie das jetzt funktionieren soll
und auf der anderen Seite die Russen haben halt mehr schwere Waffen und Flugzeuge, aber trotzdem ist es ihnen ja auch nicht bisher immer noch nicht gelungen
die Luftüberlegenheit äh eine absolute zu erlangen. Einmal weil.
Immer noch die ukrainische Luftabwehr äh noch mit dabei ist und selbst wohl die die Luftwaffe.
Auch noch äh irgendwo aktiv ist, wobei die Luftwaffe halt natürlich auch aufpassen muss, weil die Russen halt auch eine sehr gute Flugabwehr haben. Deswegen verstecken die sich sich, glaube ich, so ein so ein so ein bisschen, aber ähm ja.
So so richtig äh ähm eigentlich sieht es David oder der der Eindruck
einmal David gegen Goliath
so aber ganz so krass äh zumindest den den Zahlen nach äh scheint es scheint es nicht wirklich zu sein und insbesondere wenn es dann äh zu so einem sag mal Guerillakampf oder
zu einem Häuserkampf äh kommen sollte, äh würde den Russen wahrscheinlich nichts anderes übrig bleiben als mit schweren Waffen.
Alles in Schutt und Asche zu liegen und selbst dann ähm ja äh wird's nicht einfach. Also das ist im Prinzip Starlingrad dann äh wenn du wenn du äh äh Pech wenn die Russen Pech haben.
Also danach sieht es aber auf jeden Fall aus, dass sie jetzt sozusagen ihre Strategie schon äh geändert haben, weil die ursprüngliche Vorstellung mit sie werden da äh
Ja so wie die Amerikaner sich das äh glaube ich im Irak schon vorgestellt haben, dachten sie so ja, wir kommen da jetzt mal hin, dann geben die schon schnell auf und dann äh installieren wir hier wieder diesen Yano Covid da, unsere alte
und und dann passt das schon. Stattdessen treffen sie halt irgendwie auf einen tanzenden Schauspieler, der irgendwie Courage hat und äh,
ja nicht im Traum daran denkt hier in irgendeiner Form äh zurückzuweichen und mit seiner ganzen Vehemenz und Präsenz und und und Überzeugtheit.
Äh jetzt auf einmal so ein glaubwürdiges Symbol für die Ukraine zu sein scheint. Womit halt äh ein weiterer Faktor noch äh mit dazukommt, den du jetzt gar nicht aufgezählt hast im Kräfteverhältnis.
Die Moral, ne, die die die Motivation, also die Motivation der Ukrainer ihr Land zu verteidigen ist natürlich ohnehin hoch so, während eben so äh die Motivation vieler Russen das anzugreifen so ja,
äh warum und.
Mhm. Ja und.
Speziell natürlich dann jetzt auch noch in dieser Konstellation ist es nochmal besonders aufgeladen, ne, weil es ist halt dann auch der Kampf um Europa. Es ist irgendwie auch äh in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch nicht nur.
Ukraine kämpft irgendwie gleichzeitig gegen die Russen und für sich ja, weil äh natürlich diese.
Das ist nicht überbewerten, aber diese internationale Aufmerksamkeit, die sie jetzt endlich erhalten dadurch.
Äh etwas ist, wonach sie ja lange äh betrachtet haben und jetzt sozusagen auch bereit sind, diesen Moment für sich äh
zu nutzen, so ist Ihnen denn möglich ist und all das kommt halt noch mit rein. Und auf der anderen Seite hast du eine schlecht ausgestattete äh russische Angriffstruppe, die zwei Tage vorher überhaupt noch nicht wusste, dass sie jetzt hier irgendwie in den Krieg
zieht, der äh auf den ersten Metern schon extrem zäh anläuft, wo die ganze Logistik verschlammt wurde und wo sie auch,
ich meine mit diesem Stau, was glaube ich noch gar nicht erwähnt hast, da fragt man sich ja so, ja warum stehen die jetzt 65 Kilometer im Stau?
Ja, warum warum warum fahren die nicht einfach übern Acker und und und, und, und, und greifen einfach das ganze Land an. Na ja, ist Februar.
Und äh große Teile des Nordens des Landes, also speziell da diese Gegend um um um Kiev, soweit ich das verstanden habe, also der nördliche Bereich der Ukraine ist im Wesentlichen eine Schlammwüste.
Da kommst du nicht nicht durch. Also mit einem PKW vielleicht noch, aber eben nicht mit so einem Raketenwerfer-LKW.
Ja, beziehungsweise mit einem sozusagen selbst mit Panzer, also mit mit Radfahrzeugen irgendwie schon gar nicht und mit
Panzern kommen die ersten eins, zwei, drei Panzer noch durch, aber dann hast du das Ding auch so, ist ist das auch so matschig, dass es halt dann äh nicht so richtig weitergeht.
Ähm ja und und ähm
noch äh vielleicht eins und die sozusagen die Annahme jetzt von von Putin, dass es einen äh einen Spaziergang eigentlich werden könnte, war jetzt auch nicht
so unbedingt von der Hand zu weisen, weil zum Beispiel äh bei der Krim, bei der Besetzung der Krim gab es.
Laut Wikipedia zwei Todesopfer. Ja? Das äh in äh und.
Durch sowas, ich mein bei den anderen Provinzen war es ein bisschen bisschen mehr und dann in dem also bei den Ostprovinzen sind insgesamt jetzt glaube ich sogar fast zehntausend Leute in den in den ähm acht Jahren.
Äh seit seit zwanzig vierzehn, seit äh äh getötet worden, aber was die Krim anging, so da wurden sie wirklich als Befreier begrüßt und äh super, die Russen sind da, weil.
Auch äh dort auf der Krim wegen Korruption und äh weil äh ja irgendwelche Leute in Kiew halt die Kohle sich in die eigene Tasche gesteckt hatten,
sind halt grade öffentliche Bedienstete, Lehrer sind ver.
Monatelang. Äh ich kenne Leute persönlich, die äh Lehrer, die gesagt haben, die haben halt seit sechs Monaten kein Gehalt gesehen auf der Krim und
sich natürlich dann auch gefreut, weil als die Russen kamen, gab's dann halt auch erstmal wieder irgendwie pünktlich äh äh Löhne und Gehälter, ja.
Und ähm
Von daher, ich meine, in den anderen Osttrovinz ist nicht so gut gelaufen, weil äh die haben dann nämlich permanent äh seitdem
unter ähm ja äh Granateneinschüssen äh Einschlägen und äh Killerkommandos und was da nicht alles
alles war ähm gelitten und äh sodass das viele Leute da einfach geflohen sind, also diese diese eroberten Ostprovinzen da.
Da war's dann war's dann nicht nicht so nicht so glorreich. Aber ähm was er zum Beispiel auch vermutete irgendwie bei Khakif, äh so, da ist halt eine große.
Russische äh oder russisch-stämmige oder russisch sprachige Bevölkerung.
Das hatte er, glaube ich, gar nicht erwartet, dass dass die sich da jetzt äh so massiv äh zur Wehr setzen würden beispielsweise.
Und ähm ja in anderen Landesteilen wurden halt seit sieben Jahren jetzt auch Befestigungen, also gerade in Richtung Osten da, äh äh Gräben und
Bunker und äh was nicht alles äh gebaut. Also die haben sich da schon auch auch
teilweise vorbereitet und äh ja deswegen versuchen Nina gar nicht also von von Osten, aus dem besetzten Ostprovinzen sind die glaube ich irgendwie kein Meter
voran,
gekommen bisher, sondern nur äh dann von einer Krim aus und dann vom Norden und Nordosten äh aus äh über die über die Grenze, aber.
Die Gewinne äh sind nicht ähm groß so, ne. Das kann sich natürlich schnell äh ändern und sie versuchen hier und da auch ähm so Verbindungslinien zu machen und mehrere Fronten aufzumachen.
Gerade bei Kiew äh nähern sie sich ja von zwei Seiten.
Das könnte alles auch irgendwann nochmal militärische Implikationen haben, aber es geht auf jeden Fall äh langsam voran.
Natürlich auch ein nicht zu unterschätzender.
Vorteil ist, ich meine, das hast du als verteidigendes Land quasi ja immer im Gegensatz zu den Russen, die da äh auflaufen.
Ukrainer, die kennen sich da halt gut aus, so ne und wenn sie halt klug vorgebaut haben
dann äh äh waren sie halt auch in der Lage, ihr Land äh entsprechend vorher schon zu präparieren und in entsprechende Fallen aufzustellen und ähm,
Ladung an Brücken anzubringen et cetera. Also man sichert ja sein Land dann auch ab, wenn man irgendwie weiß, äh der Russe kommt und äh jetzt geht's unter Umständen gleich los. Mir ist
selber nicht so ganz klar wie sehr die Ukraine eigentlich mit diesem einen Marsch gerechnet hat.
Nach außen hin hat er immer gesagt, ja die passiert nix. So, aber das muss ja nach innen nicht unbedingt genauso gelaufen sein. Und es macht jetzt auch so ein bisschen so den Eindruck als als ob sie entweder jetzt sehr schnell handeln.
Oder eben auch schon vorher gehandelt äh haben. Haben Sie nicht irgendwie äh.
Den die ganzen Verkehrsschilder äh demontiert.
Ja, das war, glaube ich, eine Aktion sozusagen von einer Firma.
Die eigentlich so für für Schilder aufstellen und aufbauen oder so zuständig ist. Die äh haben sie sich dann zum Ziel gemacht eben rumzufahren und äh dann äh ja die die.
Schilder dann entsprechend entweder abzubauen oder zu defacen mit ich meine am Anfang äh ging ja durch die durch die Presse so diese Schilder, wo dann irgendwie Fuck You äh Fuck You
und äh äh go back to russia and fuck you there äh so auf Ukrainisch
und dann ja die letzte Variante äh äh keine Ahnung, ob das die Leute dort äh auch verstehen, sie wahrscheinlich auch,
aber wo dann alle drei Richtungsfeile so auf der Autobahn irgendwie mit den Haag, den Haag, den Haag gekennzeichnet äh waren.
Ja und äh ja äh.
Da äh und Den Haag ist ja Sitz so sowohl vom vom äh ICJ, eine International Course of Justice, die ist schon seit Ewigkeiten äh gibt. Das ist so der dann so.
Eher über.
Internationale Kriegsstreitigkeiten, äh also über über Völkerrecht, äh mehr äh urteilt. So wenn und dann aber äh eben auch den den.
International Kriminal Court, den ICC, der dann so für die Verfolgung auch von Kriegsverbrechern äh äh verantwortlich ist so.
Und äh ja, ich denke mal, beide werden äh in Zukunft auch tatsächlich mit diesem Krieg äh beschäftigt äh sein, sowohl ja.
Eindruck. Auf jeden Fall, das ist so ein bisschen die militärische äh Situation. Es ging nicht voran. Und nach ein paar Tagen, das ist
ging nicht voran.
Ja und jetzt kommen wir so an so einen so einen kritischen äh Punkt, so diese Eskalation im im Krieg, die erste zumindest, die die jetzt äh sicht.
Am Anfang rollten sie an, es gibt viele Berichte von Scharmützeln und gekaperten Tanks hier und über laufende Soldaten da und Rückschlägen und Rückeroberungen von dem und dem Flughafen alles sehr unübersichtlich.
Aber die Russen scheinen jetzt schon so ein bisschen auf diese Grossnimmethode zurückzugreifen, wo sie halt sagen, also wenn man jetzt hier nicht schnell vorankommt.
Ballern wir einfach alles kurz und klein ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste, solange bis sie aufgegeben wird, weil wir haben hier einfach zu gewinnen.
Und das tun sie halt, ne? Also es ist halt eigentlich ein einziges äh Kriegsverbrechen, was mittlerweile dort äh stattfindet, also Bombardements, von Wohngebieten.
Ohne Ende die Universitäten werden beschossen. Das äh nimmt überhaupt gar kein Ende und das ist natürlich Terror, ne. Das ist halt einfach äh Mürbe machen.
Der Bevölkerung äh dabei wird natürlich ein extremer äh Schaden zugefügt nicht nur an an Leuten, die,
sterben, verletzt werden. Natürlich auch Wohnungen, ne, ganze Gebiete, die äh wahrscheinlich danach äh unbewohnbar sein werden
So sind nicht konsequent wieder aufgebaut werden und das ist natürlich so das das Prinzip der verbrannten Erde, so nach dem Motto wir hauen euch hier einfach kurz und klein und ist auch egal wie es euch geht so wir äh
weil wir sind ja eure Brüder und wir wollen euch ja von den Nazis retten. Das die ganze Story passt auch wirklich und vorne nicht zusammen.
Haben sie dann auch noch irgendwie äh das Holocaust äh die Holocaust-Gedenkstätte auch noch irgendwie bombardiert. Ja.
Ja ich glaube ähm das war aber äh da haben sie irgendwie den Fernsehturm verfehlt oder so äh ähm.
Nicht, dass sie.
Sich dafür Sorgen drum gemacht hätten.
Und ganz und wie gesagt so mit allergrößter Präzision äh gehen die da jetzt auch nicht gerade äh vor. Wobei.
Schon natürlich sichtbar war auch äh das je nachdem um was für Truppen es sich handelt, hat man ja auch gesehen, dass sie schon,
auch äh davor zurückschrecken, jetzt die Zivilbevölkerung, also dass sie sich durchaus auch durch Blockaden einfach von Leuten, die sich auf die Straße gestellt haben.
Bis hin zu äh der eine Typ, der sich dann äh diesem
kompletten Militärkonvoi entgegengestellt hatten und dann die Militärfahrzeuge äh um ihn herumkurvten, um ihm bloß nicht zu überfahren und so, also weil das wäre natürlich aber auch, also so was, solche Bilder, wo dann irgendwie Panzer über Menschen äh äh rüberfahren. Ich meine, da gab's ja diese eine Szene, wo
auch ähm irgendeinen
Luftabwehrpanzer der von der Ukraine gestohlen wurde von irgendwelchen russischen Sabotagetrupps äh dann über einen PKW gefahren ist, der ihm.
So nicht in direkt entgegen kam, sondern auf der anderen Spurenecke und.
Rüber, wobei der der Bann, der da drin saß, wundersamerweise, überlebt hat, aber das sind natürlich Bilder.
Dann die man natürlich auch nicht haben möchte so und
Plus, äh das natürlich auch die normalen Soldaten äh durchaus Hemmungen haben, jetzt einfach Zivilisten äh zu überfahren. Das das will halt
glaube ich glaube ich keiner ähm so richtig und ähm ja also.
Ja, zu den ich meine, wenn wir jetzt schon beim bei den militärischen Szenarien äh äh sind äh so, da gab's einen ganz interessanten.
Ähm.
Auf irgendwie Table Punkt äh Media mit sechs Szenarien für einen möglichen Ausgang. Ich hätte irgendwie noch zwei weitere Szenarien, aber die sind dort halt auch ganz gut eigentlich.
Ausformuliert und und begründet und auch wie wahrscheinlich das das Ganze ist so sage und,
dort ist das erste mögliche Szenario, dass halt Russland siegt so und äh die Regierung.
Dann Moskau und eine Marionetten-Regierung äh installiert und dann halt einen,
entsprechend autoritäres Regime mit entsprechend ja wenn ich Sicherheitskräften und Verfolgen der Opposition und Massenverhaftungen und so versucht dann der,
Proteste äh Herr zu werden.
Durch verbunden mit entsprechenden Fluchtbewegungen, wo sich dann die ganzen Arbeitskräfte und die jungen äh Elite und Unternehmer absetzen und äh ja äh dann die Investitionen nicht wiederkommen und dann wahrscheinlich die Chinesen da reingehen.
Den im Übrigen sowieso schon ähm also mindestens fünf Prozent
wahrscheinlich mittlerweile eher größenordnungsmäßig 10 Prozent des ukrainischen Bodens gehören also jetzt ja mhm,
die haben sich da äh eingekauft, also,
2tausend4zehn waren's oder waren's schon fünf Prozent und weiß nicht wie viel seitdem noch dazugekommen äh ist so, weil ich meine, das haben sie ja in aller Welt gemacht, die Chinesen, um halt Nahrungsmittel
Quellen zu zu sichern und die sind da halt auch mit
äh ganz gut mit drin und dann natürlich spielen halt Öl- und Gasinteressen auch eine Rolle.
Was in in den Teilen wurden die Lizenzen wiederum überwiegend an amerikanische englischer, also an westliche Ölfirmen vergeben äh so. Das passt zu den Russen natürlich auch nicht so, wobei,
ähm die wegen Technologie und und und anderem äh auch äh viele westliche Ölkonzerne im im Land haben, aber ähm ja
Da sind eben auch auch viele wirtschaftliche Interessen von, wie gesagt, auch China und und dem,
besten mittlerweile äh betroffen. Ähm ja also.
Das ist so ein eins Szenario so Russland kriegt zwar das Land aber die guten Leute hauen ab und äh ja.
Ähm und die äh und ähm ja.
Sanktionen äh bleiben und äh ja.
Geht für keinen gut aus sozusagen.
Es geht nicht so richtig gut aus. Aber ja, Putin kann dann halt sagen, irgendwie hat's äh hat die Ukraine Heim ins Reich geholt und äh ja. So.
Ein zweites dort ja wahrscheinliches Szenario ist wird hiermit humanitäre Kapitulation bezeichnet.
Ähm wo was so ein bisschen dem Szenario eins,
ähnelt, nur äh dass es halt äh früher Schluss ist, weil
die Ukraine zur Vermeidung, weil weitere Opfern ein Diktat äh Frieden der russischen Seite.
Akzeptiert, so und formal unabhängig bleibt aber dann zu einem Vasallenstaat wird und die Regierung ins Exil geht und auch wieder Migrationsbewegungen und äh ja
äh was dann am Ende zu einer, wie's so schön heißt,
stabilen Blockkonfrontation zwischen Russland und dem Westen führt und äh in Verbindung dann mit einer massiven Aufrüstung
äh jetzt NATO und EU äh wo ja äh wir dann äh größere Mengen an Truppen äh entlang äh.
Dann der NATO beziehungsweise EU-Ostgrenze äh stationiert haben werden.
So ja als Szenario drei ist dort äh was als möglich äh gesehen wird.
Angesehen wird, dauerhafter Partisankrieg. Also im Grunde genommen so ein bisschen Afghanistan Variante.
Was natürlich
auch dann einhergeht mit hohen Kosten und schlechten Lebensbedingungen und Beibehaltung der Sanktionen und einem Rüstungswettlauf und ja,
was auch zu einer wirtschaftlichen Abhängigkeit von von China zu mehr wirtschaftlichen Abhängigkeit Russlands von China äh führen würde und eben auch.
Massive ähm Rückfall auch der der russischen äh äh Wirtschaft so das wäre halt für für Russland sehr schlimm.
Weiteres Szenario ähm dort Friedensschluss und Finanzierung äh wie sie es wie sie es nennen. So.
Ähm ja äh.
Und äh das äh würde bedeuten, dass die Ukraine einen formalen, neutral und blockfrei und als Scharnier.
Fungiert. Ich äh und halt die, die Westperspektive quasi verendet.
Beendet wird und auch einen EU-Beitritt ausgeschlossen.
Wird. Äh allerdings unter den Bedingungen dann sozusagen eine Teilaufhebung äh von Sanktionen erfolgt und äh ja äh Handel mit Russland und
der Ukraine äh wieder in in Gang kommt und man dann so eine na ja,
so eine Art äh weiß ich nicht ja halbkalter Krieg oder lauwarmer Krieg oder wie auch immer man das man das nennen will zwei null wo ja alles irgendwie,
so auf auf halber.
Auf halber Flamme äh läuft. Also alles alles halb so schlimm, aber auch nur halb so gut ist, könnte man äh so äh.
Okay, Finnland, so im Sinne von so wie Finnland jetzt.
Ja ja, ja. Also das sozusagen die die.
Finnland jetzt auch dazu tendiert äh in die NATO aufgenommen.
Ja ja. Ja, aber das ist sozusagen mit also im im Hinblick auf quasi den ähm den den russisch-finnischen Krieg
im Vorfeld des zweiten Weltkriegs, der ja wo die Finnen ja auch erst mal massiven Widerstand
äh entgegengesetzt, haben aber am Ende dann schon
verloren äh haben äh und Landesteile abtreten mussten, aber äh dann äh ja ähm sagen schon Finnland ähm dann Finnland geblieben
und äh ja, aber seitdem eben neutral.
Ist und deswegen glaube ich haben sie's halt finanzierung äh genannt. So und.
Ja, jetzt kommt's Szenario fünf. Das, was halt als extrem unwahrscheinlich gesehen wird, nämlich eine humanitäre Intervention des Westens.
So äh dass äh halt irgendwann äh Länder dort also Truppen aus dem Westen.
In der Ukraine einmarschieren und eine humanitäre Schutzzone errichten, ohne aber direkt jetzt russische Truppen anzugreifen.
Also im Prinzip, was wir so ein bisschen auch in Jugoslawien teilweise.
Gesehen haben und äh dann die Ukraine halt dann äh mindestens zweigeteilt ist mit dem Akkations äh Linien so.
Auch äh mit zwei verschiedenen Regierungssitzen so einmal äh sagenden Landesteil unter West-Einfluss, sondern Landesteil unter Ost Einfluss auch so ein bisschen wie,
Deutsche Teilung im Grunde genommen, könnte man auch sagen ähm.
Nicht. Das würde ja dann auch mit äh einschließen, ne.
Ja, ja, aber ich ja, es ist wie gesagt, aber das ich ich halte auch das Szenario vier irgendwie
diese Finlatisierungsvariante dazu ist halt jetzt einfach zu viel passiert. Dazu ist jetzt irgendwie also dazu ist das zu sehr hochgekocht und äh mittlerweile zu sehr
polarisiert äh das das das Ganze und das das wäre eher eine Variante gewesen, wenn ähm ja
äh weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht so wie gesagt bei Finnland damals äh lief's ja dann auch so, obwohl äh sich,
dort die Russen eben auch eine blutige Nase geholt haben, äh hat man dann hinterher äh ja äh Finnland
leben lassen, sage ich mal und nicht annickt.
Wir müssen ja eh noch die Reaktion äh des Westens jetzt ähm noch äh aufgreifen, bevor wir da abschließend machen können stehen noch mal so die restlichen Szenarien vor und dann gucken wir mal.
Immer die schnell noch noch durch.
Ja, wie gesagt, die also das Szenario 5 wie gesagt wäre diese humanitäre Intervention des Westens, wo dann eben Schutzzonen eingerichtet werden und äh dann
sagen's das letzte Szenario, was dort geschildert wird, ist, dass Russland sich zurückzieht, weil sagen durch Sanktionen und Verluste und Massen äh äh
und äh Unruhe in der russischen Elite es irgendwie zum
zum Umdenken kommt und äh die sich ins äh die Russen sich halt von sich aus weitgehend äh zurück
ziehen und äh ja
ähm trotzdem ja wirtschaftlicher, schwerer, wirtschaftlicher Schaden und äh ja äh und
auch weitere ähm
ja weiteres äh ranrücken von Russland an an China und äh so.
Ja und ich hätte jetzt noch äh wie gesagt noch einen noch einen weiteres äh Szenario äh so nämlich, dass ähm
ja die Ukraine, die ja sowohl den Manpower als auch den Willen hat äh dermaßen jetzt vom
Westen mit äh Material, Waffen und äh Munition vollgepumpt und versorgt wird, bis sie an einigen Stellen äh tatsächlich äh ja die äh äh russische,
Armee äh dort wirklich vernichten oder aus dem Land äh treiben. So das halte ich vielleicht auch nicht für das wahrscheinlichste Szenario, aber auch durchaus für ein mögliches Szenario, also sprich
ähm dass äh ja äh also die ich würde die Ukraine nicht völlig
schreiben, auch wenn äh kaum jemand damit rechnet, dass sie dass dass sie das gewinnen würden, halte ich ein Szenario äh was natürlich auch super bitter äh ist und irgendwie super brutal äh äh wäre.
Aber das äh tatsächlich ja äh wegen.
Ja besserer Moral Heimatkenntnis und mehr mehr.
Mehr Soldaten und wenn die jetzt noch mit entsprechend Waffen und Material äh versorgt werden.
So. Ich meine, wenn wir den zweiten Weltkrieg anguckst, sah's halt auch erst mal nicht so aus, als das die Russen da.
Lange gegen Deutschland standhalten würden. Das war ja auch erst mal ein ein Westfalen eine super blutiger Konflikt, so,
operation Barbarossa. Ich glaube, du hast zwei Millionen Tote innerhalb von wenigen Wochen.
Nochmal eine ganz andere Dimension jetzt als dieser Konflikt. Aber gut ähm
ja ich halte das auch nicht für ausgeschlossen, dass äh ja es das die Kämpfe sich erst mal hinziehen und dass dass dann aber Russland irgendwann äh Materialmäßig äh und man powermäßig die
die Puste ausgeht, während halt der Rest der Welt äh dort Material und Waffen äh ohne Ende reinpumpt und die Russen dann tatsächlich
auch wieder zurückgetrieben werden über die Grenze, ja? Das ist ich sage zwar nicht das Wahrscheinlichste Szenario, aber jetzt auch nicht völlig ausgeschlossen.
Ich meine das ist etwas, was man, was man sehr schwer, ich meine, das ist in gewisser Hinsicht so ein bisschen so wie so ein Idealvorstellung, ne, so dass man irgendwie so dem dem
dem Aggressor widerstehen kann und so hintenrum ohne eigene Verluste, nur indem man äh die Industrie hochkurbelt und äh Waffen liefert.
Da äh einen positiven Ausgang macht. Ich meine äh militärisch ist das für uns schwer einzuschätzen, aber
Ist schon so, dass in diesem asymmetrischen äh Kampf man natürlich mit mit weniger eine ganze Menge äh erzielen kann, ne, also grad so diese Panzerabwehr äh Raketen, die da mehr zum äh,
Einsatz kommen, die da einfach von jedermann äh einfach zu bedienen sind und von jedem Haus abgeschossen werden können. Das kann natürlich irgendwie die Russen schon echt strafen und irgendwann wird halt dann äh den Leuten auch auffallen.
Die nicht äh zurückkommen.
Na ja das ist das ist halt auch so ein Ding was sich geändert hat natürlich gerade
mit zu Waffen äh jetzt mit moderneren Waffen. Wobei was heißt modern? Die sind halt auch teilweise
also das Dinger ist glaube ich auch jetzt irgendwie fast 30 oder 40 Jahre alt. Genauso die aber die sind natürlich jetzt jetzt immer weiter aufgerüstet worden.
Und äh diese sind halt so Panzerabwehrraketen, die,
im Gegensatz zu dem was die deutsche Bundeswehr hat, Rudi hat glaube ich auch jetzt ein paar aber die hat hauptsächlich Milan immer noch ich meine die war schon zu meiner Zeit beim Bund äh sagen war, dass das Ding mit dem wir geschossen haben.
Panzerabwehr war für Milan.
Äh eine Rakete, die spulten Draht ab, wenn die fliegt und über den Draht wird die dann ferngesteuert und du musst halt den das Ziel, in dem Fall den gegnerischen Panzer, die ganze Zeit im Visier halten, während die Rakete fliegt.
Das heißt, sie fliegt dahin, wo
du jetzt dein Fadenkreuz hinzeigst und wenn du halt rechts bewegst, links also die ja so funktioniert halt die Milan.
Ist aber ein bisschen blöd, weil die braucht halt schon ein bisschen und die ist dann im Anflug und
dann ja wissen die natürlich auch ganz schnell wo du wo du steckst während die Jefflin, teilten Infrarotsuchkopf und gehört halt zu denen wie es so schön heißt Fire and Forget
Waffen und kann eben auch offiziell bis auf zwei Kilometer Entfernung, aber es wurden auch schon äh Treffer auf bis zu vier Kilometern ähm so äh ja
ähm beobachtet. Das heißt, das sind so Entfernungen. Das heißt, da.
Das Ding, ähm wenn du das musst du nur einmal das das das Ziel so
was weiß ich den Panzermotor kurz ins Visier kriegen, feuerst ab und kannst dann
wegrennen und dich dich verstecken während dann halt die Rakete ja innerhalb von je nach Entfernung halten das dann schon mehrere Sekunden Flugzeit
Sprengköpfe sind zwar nicht so super groß, aber einen Treffer reicht dann typischerweise schon aus, um den Panzer aus der Gefecht
äh zu setzen und äh ja, je nachdem, wo.
Außerdem außerdem haben die noch das Feature, dass äh wenn sie starten machen sie es noch nicht gleich mit der vollen Power, sondern die hüpfen dir erstmal so ein bisschen vom Leib.
Zünden dann erst äh so nach einer Sekunde in zehn Meter Entfernung irgendwie erst so richtig äh durch. Das erlaubt dir sozusagen auch schon.
Das auch in Situationen zu machen, wo so die volle Power einer solchen startenden
Schulterrakete für den Ort unangemessen wäre, also kannst du was weiß ich, in so einem Häuser ausm Haus heraus. Ne, du schubst sie quasi erstmal nur raus und dann startet sie durch und dann
fliegt sie auch noch extrem nach oben.
Und trifft das Ding quasi nicht frontal, sondern fliegt so, dass sie das äh den Panzer dann halt in dem Fall äh von oben trifft, womit die dann halt besonders.
Verletzlich sind.
Und davon sind halt jetzt auch äh wahrscheinlich tausende von den Dingern, weil du immer unterscheiden musst zwischen der Abschussvorrichtung und dann den den den Geschossen äh so bei den bei den Zahlen selber bei den bei den Stinger
Raketen, die dann wiederum zur zur Luft,
genutzt sind, wobei Bundeswehr liefert ja jetzt auch noch irgendwie Strelas aus NVA-Beständen, das ist so wird's so ein bisschen die die russische Stinger eigentlich äh also auch mit.
Luftabwehrrakete mit Infrarotsuchkopf, die auch beim Bundes bei der Bundeswehr ist, dass dann Fliegerfaust eins,
die Stinger, dann die Fliegerfaust zwei äh ist. Beim Bund und.
Ja und diese dieses Dingers sind halt auch fies also gegen Hubschrauber im Afghanistan-Krieg äh waren achtzig Prozent
Trefferrate und sogar gegen Kampfflugzeuge, also gegen gegen Jets.
Ungefähr zehn Prozent, je nachdem gegen welche und und so aber größenordnungsmäßig zehn Prozent, das heißt du kannst mit den Dingern sogar auch Jets runterholen, auch wenn wenn äh aber ja
wenn zehn Leute da stehen mit so einem Ding äh kannst du sogar halt moderne Jets, äh wenn die nicht zu hoch äh fliegen. Aber die Dinger gehen glaube ich bis dreitausend Meter.
Auch also insofern ja äh fiese, wirklich fiese kleine äh Waffen, die eben auch so eine gewisse Asymmetrie dann dann
in das in das Ganze reinbringen. Aber was die Russen dann halt äh wiederum auf der anderen Seite haben, sind halt
ihre Raketen, die und und ja schwere Artillerie, die dann das Zehnhundert- oder Tausendfache an Sprengkraft haben im Vergleich jetzt zu einer Stinger und wo du im Grunde genommen ein Treffer äh ein ganzes Gebäude in in Schutt und Asche mit,
legen kannst, wie wir ja auch jetzt gesehen haben leider. Ähm ja.
Es wird dann auch sehr viel vermutet darüber, welche äh illegalen Waffensysteme sonst noch so zum Einsatz kommen. Ich glaube, da gibt's auch schon äh Berichte, kann ich aber nicht bewerten.
Cluster.
Klasser äh ähm Waffen, also die sozusagen irgendwo einschlagen, sich in viele kleine aufteilen und dann so ein riesiges Gebiet absprengen äh bis hin zur ich glaube das ist aber noch nicht.
Tätig, dass das wirklich stattgefunden hat. Da gab's auf jeden Fall auch noch so ein paar Fake- äh Sachen, aber das ist zumindest auch so eine Befürchtung, weil die Russen so was definitiv in ihrem Programm haben. Diese thermobarischen.
Waffen.
Diese äh Waffen ja mhm.
Böses Zeug, wo dann halt so quasi so erstmal äh Aerosol äh durch eine Erstsprengung verteilt wird, die dann mit einer zweiten äh gleich hinterher gezündet wird, die dann einfach einem riesigen Gebiet quasi so den Sauerstoff äh entzieht und dabei aber so ein Unter,
erzeugt, dass das dadurch halt irgendwie die.
Ja nicht wirklich nicht nicht wirklich. Das ist also das mit dem Unterdruck äh ist äh also da wurde auch einiges irgendwie also was stimmt es sozusagen der der erste
Teil des, dass die ähm ja, dass die im Prinzip ja
Diesel oder äh halt äh ja irgendeinem Kohlenwasserstoff,
gemischt dann fein zerstäuben und dann auch zünden und dabei eben auch,
sagen natürlich den sich den Sauerstoff aus der Luft holen, also bei normalen was weiß ich, bei TNT oder Hexogen oder so, hast du sozusagen den den Sauerstoff, den Oxidator
mit drin, das heißt äh wenn du jetzt, ich sage mal ein Kilogramm TNT hast, äh hat
dass äh ungefähr nur einen einen Viertel der Energie, als wenn du ein Kilogramm
Diesel zerstäubst und dann mit Hilfe des Sauerstoffs aus der Luft zündest. Das heißt, du hast halt erst mal pro pro Gewicht ungefähr das das Vierfache an an Energie.
Und natürlich weil es den Sauerstoff dort auch verbrennt
so ist dann zwar auch kein Sauerstoff da, aber das ist jetzt das geringste Problem, weil da ist ein Feuerball, ja.
Und ob da jetzt Sauerstoff ist oder nicht, äh wenn du dich in einem Feuerball befindest, ist das äh ist das,
sagen das geringste Problem. Aber weil die halt auch so energetisch sind, gibt's halt eben eine extreme Schockwelle und.
Da ist es einfach so ganz dir vorstellen mhm
diese Schockwelle, da kommt jetzt, ich sage mal, mit einem Bar Luftdruck von einer Seite und hinter dir ist halt,
äh also von vorne zwei Bar und von hinten nur ein Bar hast du plötzlich was halt bedeutet, äh dass äh sagen dein Körper plötzlich einem Druck von ein Kilogramm.
Pro Quadratzentimeter äh ausgesetzt ist. Das heißt, äh dass sich diese Druckwelle ungefähr so eine Einbahndruckwelle
die bewegt sich dann auch mit Schallgeschwindigkeit vor, ist halt ungefähr wie äh wenn äh ja der jemand äh irgendwie,
eine eine eine Stahlplatte mit äh Schallgeschwindigkeit äh so mit dem Druck von äh weil nicht menschliche Körperoberfläche zwei Quadratmeter oder so.
Im Grunde genommen dann mit mit zwei Tonnen äh sagen zwei Tonnen Druck mit Schallgeschwindigkeit und so, das das tötet dich auch einfach die Druckwelle. So
ja. Deswegen.
Okay, also auf jeden Fall schlimmes Zeug so, ne?
Ja, aber mit Vakuum, also Vakuum ja ist da nicht wirklich. Äh.
Vakuum hast du ja Vakuumeffekte treten manchmal auf bei äh sozusagen unter Wasser, wenn wir nur irgendwie unter Wasser
ja, aber egal. Aber jedenfalls mit Vakuum hat das nichts zu tun und mit dem mit dem Sauerstoff
raussaugen, klingt jetzt irgendwie auch in der Presse spektakulär, aber im Grunde genommen ist es ein Feuerball, in dem du verbrennst oder eine Druckwelle, die dich die dich halt äh ja sofort tötet.
Auf jeden Fall
krasse Scheiße, alles nicht äh mit dem Menschenrechtskonventionen und Kriegsgesetzen und so weiter alles nicht vereinbar, alles äh großes Potential für äh Den Haag.
Aber die haben das und sie haben auch mehrfach gezeigt, dass ihnen irgendwie zu Den Haag eigentlich ziemlich scheißegal ist, weil sie müssen da irgendjemand durch und dann ist ihnen irgendwie alles Wurst, so diesen Eindruck macht die russische Armee,
jeden Fall. Wir sollten jetzt vielleicht mal so ein bisschen auf die Reaktion des Westens kommen, denn.
Der war ja vor allem von äh Verzweiflung geprägt. Man wusste halt nicht so richtig, was man machen soll, weil du mal die Situation so ist.
Russland angreifen, mit Russland in einen unmittelbaren direkten Konflikt zu kommen.
Irgendwie so ein bisschen das No-Go, weil.
Potenziell Weltkrieg und Zerstörung und alles noch viel schlimmer. Sprich in dem Moment, wo man gerne Russland einhängen möchte, na ja, dann macht man halt irgendwie Druck.
Nachdem irgendwie durch diesen Aufmarsch klar war, oh Gott da da brennt die Hütte.
Hat man sich halt überlegt, okay, was machen wir jetzt? Womit können wir ohne äh hier selber mit eigenem Kriegsgerät und und Kriegslogistik an Start zu gehen
Russland so nachhaltig beeindrucken, dass sie von ihrem Plan absehen.
Und haben dann eben weitreichende Wirtschaftssanktionen angekündigt mit dem schönen Teckline, die Mutter aller Sanktionen und das lag dann so aufm Tisch und Putin so, ja mir noch egal, ich greife jetzt an.
Und ähm dann.
Kamen, die aber auch. Also nach, es hat so ein, zwei Tage gedauert, bis sich das alles so zusammengeruckelt hat und alle vermuteten schon so, ah ja, hier der Westen wieder und so, ne. Erst mal groß rumtönen und wenn dann was passiert, dann äh.
Dann passiert wieder nix, ne? Auf eurer Seite, aber mitnichten, man muss sagen, sie sind.
Sogar noch weitergegangen, als sie eigentlich ursprünglich angekündigt haben.
Wobei ich das vorausgesehen habe. Ha ha. Dass das so kommen wird. Ähm dass äh dass das Sanktions
mäßig äh weiter äh eskalieren äh äh wird,
also das war mir am am zweiten Tag äh sagen nach dem nach dem Einmarsch äh war mir das völlig klar noch bevor die großen Sanktionen gab, dass einfach,
bei diesen Bildern, äh die da kommen und bei dieser äh also letztlich sind es ja auch auch immer Geschichten oder Erzählungen, die politisch am meisten bewirken oder bewegen, ja.
So und da war jetzt plötzlich eine Geschichte und und und Bilder, mit denen die Welt konfrontiert war, die
zu geführt haben, dass auch gerade im Westen so die Politiker das Gefühl hatten, also wenn wir da jetzt nichts was machen
dann äh so, dann lacht uns unsere eigene Bevölkerung aus oder oder fängt an uns zu hassen. Das heißt.
Und sie konnten sich natürlich auch es sind halt auch Menschen, die konnten sich halt auch diesen Bildern und diesen Geschichten äh nicht
entziehen so und deswegen äh ja hatte ich halt äh vermutet, dass es sehr wahrscheinlich
äh ja äh auch auf westlicher Seite eskalieren wird und zwar je schlimmer die Bilder äh äh werden, die da kommen, umso mehr kommt auch äh aus dem Westen und.
Ja und wie du schon richtig sagtest, äh so ja äh ist das wirklich äh nicht übertrieben,
Das ist das krasseste Sanktionspaket ist glaube ich was jemals,
aufgelegt wurde äh beziehungsweise vergleichbar nur mit äh Sanktionen gegen Nordkorea oder ähm.
Iran, ja, ja so dass es genau die, also im Grunde genommen die selbe Kategorie äh von von Sanktionen äh.
Vielleicht sogar an manchen Stellen noch noch noch einen Ticken drauf gelegt äh als gegenüber.
Definitiv. Also was ist passiert? Ähm zunächst einmal gab's und das ist ja auch angekündigt oder das war zumindest das wurde schon vorher gemutmaßt oder.
Klang schon durch, das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau.
Man hat äh dem Großteil der russischen Banken ähm den Zugriff auf Swift.
Äh entzogen. Swift ist dieses in Brüssel basierte.
Zahlungsabwicklungszentralsystem, was wir alle irgendwie kennen, der Swiftcode oder der BIC-Code so. Also jede Bank ist dort registriert mit einem entsprechenden Code und ähm man kann halt über Swift Zahlungen abwickeln.
Sich gegenseitig Geld schicken kann. Das Ganze liegt aber unter europäischer Kontrolle und dementsprechend können die Europäer auch sagen, so äh.
Was ihr wollt, aber hier spielt ihr nicht mehr mit und wenn man da halt rausfliegt, dann ist das schon mal nicht so geil. War am Anfang ein bisschen umstritten, weil es natürlich auch bedeutet.
Zum Beispiel Deutschland seine Gas äh.
Die sie aus Russland ja noch beziehen äh auch darüber bezahlen möchte. Deswegen hat man sich da auf so eine gestaffelte Firewall ähm geeinigt, wo halt bestimmte Banken dann doch noch freigelassen sind, ne.
Ich weiß nicht, ob's da noch filigranere äh Filter gibt da drauf, um da Missbrauch zu verhindern. Das kann alles sein, das weiß ich nicht. Nur wurde das halt im Vorfeld alles so als.
Oh das ist jetzt das schärfste Schwert, was äh Europa so äh einen Gürtel stecken hat, stellt sich raus, stimmt gar nicht.
Das ist mehr sagen wir mal so ähm Swift an sich ist einerseits jetzt ich sage mal Presse,
mäßig oder oder in der Öffentlichkeit wurde das halt halt sehr hoch gehandelt äh und es ist halt relevant äh für Länder
die sich den Sanktionen nicht in der Form,
angeschlossen haben direkt. Das heißt, die werden quasi auch mit abgehängt, wenn du so willst,
was die Energielieferungen angeht, äh die können Sie zur Not auch einen Kurier schicken mit entsprechendem
Papier ja um äh die die die Zahlung zu tätigen, also die ganz großen für die ganz Großen Geschäfte äh braucht man's nicht.
Aber
für die zigtausend kleineren äh äh Unternehmen und grade Technologie, Unternehmen und viele andere. Äh die können jetzt äh gut.
Also sozusagen das äh
wodurch das, ich sage mal, fast überflüssig geworden wäre äh oder weshalb ähm sagen das andere ein stärkeres äh Schwert ist, ist tatsächlich die Sanktionen in dem Sinne des Verbot Geschäfte zu machen.
Ja. Weil wenn du nicht Geschäfte machen darfst, so, dann ist egal, ob irgendwie du bezahlen kannst oder nicht. Äh so wenn das Land sagt, irgendwie.
Nö, keine Geschäfte mit russischen Firmen, aber es macht natürlich auch die Umgehung ein bisschen bisschen schwieriger dann und auch Länder eben, die dann,
sagen sagen wir machen trotzdem noch oder wir würden trotzdem noch Geschäfte mit Russland machen äh so auch äh die äh denen wird das dann massiv erschwert durch die äh durch die durch den Swift
Ausschluss, das noch zu tun.
Ja, aber sie haben dann noch ein ein zweites Finanzinstrument ausgepackt, nämlich ähm da bin ich mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz so sicher, wie das eigentlich genau organisiert ist, aber de facto haben sie die,
Also die Geldreserven der russischen Zentralbank, die in Euro vorliegen und in Dollar.
Die Devisenreserven.
Die Devisenreserven, also sozusagen Euros, die den Russen gehören, die aber in Europa liegen.
In Amerika äh liegen, ja. Und ähm.
Eingefroren. Mit anderen Worten kriegt er nicht.
Also die sind äh genau, das macht wohl, glaube ich, ich meine, wurde ja gesagt, okay Russland hat irgendwie 6hundert Milliarden äh an Devisenreserven
angehäuft und ungefähr die.
Die Hälfte davon äh glaube ich ist jetzt äh durch diese äh Zentralbankblockade erstmal nicht nicht zu greifbar, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Ähm also ich habe so verstanden, dass 640 Milliarden sind, dass ungefähr ein Drittel äh Euro und US-Dollar ausmacht. Äh ein weiteres Drittel liegt nur in Gold vor.
Ja und Gold ist natürlich auch nicht die auch nicht super äh liquide und so. Also was ich gehört habe ist gut, wir haben halt noch ein bisschen Bargeld in ihren Tresoren in in Russland rumliegen und eben wie gesagt Gold.
So sich gehört habe, ungefähr die Hälfte der Devisenreserven äh sind erstmal nicht nicht nutzbar. So für die für die Russen.
Und das Geld fehlt ihnen natürlich jetzt.
Einfach um den Staat zu finanzieren und das äh fehlt ihnen vor allem um ihre eigene Währung zu stabilisieren, was ja eine der Aufgaben der
Zentralbanken sind und der Rubel geht seit Kriegsbeginn in den Keller und äh ich weiß gerade nicht, wie der Kurs ist hier gerade äh ist.
Wollen wir mal gucken.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe ist ungefähr hat ein Drittel seines Wertes verloren wenn ich das richtig sehe seit Beginn des Konflikts.
Ja. Ähm.
Plus das natürlich ja Apple so also ja oder bleiben wir mal bei den bei den Dicken, bei den Großen.
Ja, ich will erst mal diese ganze Finanzsituation ähm mal machen.
Also der Rubel singt im Wert. Das bedeutet natürlich, dass das Vermögen, was die Russen in.
Ihrer eigenen Währung haben. In dem Moment, wo sie in irgendeiner Form internationale Güter kaufen wollen, weniger wert ist.
Ja, also sozusagen Importe haben sich jetzt für die Russen äh um ein Drittel verteuert schlagartig.
Genau. So und äh ich glaube das Umtauschen ist jetzt auch irgendwie begrenzt. Das äh wird den Leuten nicht erlaubt oder es gibt auch irgendeine Grenze, weiß ich nicht ganz genau.
Aber es wird auf jeden Fall teurer, das heißt Wertverlust, Wertverlust, Wertverlust. Und durch diese ganzen wirtschaftlichen Blockaden ziehen sich natürlich jetzt zahlreiche Unternehmen zurück. Also ähm von.
Sie halt den Handel aussetzen beziehungsweise halt gar nicht mehr liefern dürfen, Chips nicht mehr geliefert werden darf, Hochtechnologie nicht mehr also eigentlich gar nichts mehr geliefert werden darf,
mit der Ausnahme von Lebensmitteln und Medikamenten und gab glaube ich noch irgendwie ein, zwei Ausnahmen von irgendwas, aber im Wesentlichen ist so das Allermeiste an wirtschaftlicher Aktivität ist schlicht und ergreifend einfach verboten.
Beziehungsweise ziehen sich halt auch Unternehmen komplett zurück. Bestes Beispiel.
Oder sichtbarstes oder populärstes Beispiel ist IKEA, die nicht weniger als 17 Standorte in Russland äh haben und in Weißrussland, die sie jetzt äh alle zumachen.
Alle schließen ab soweit ich sehe auch nicht nur vorübergehend schließen, sondern so richtig.
Das war's. Bin mir jetzt nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber auch das ganze für ihre eigenen Waren, die sie verkaufen, also alles, was in Russland und Weißrussland produziert wurde für IKEA, sagen sie auch ab.
Die von den von den größten Shipping Companies,
Mersk und so weiter, Hapag-Lloyd und so weiter, die liefern jetzt auch nichts mehr an. Also es gibt jetzt also mit der Ausnahme wiederum von Nahrungsmitteln.
Der ganze Container, Frachtverkehr nach Russland ist mehr oder weniger zusammengebrochen.
Und vor allem auch große ähm Partnerunternehmen speziell auch im Ölbereich ziehen sich jetzt zurück,
und gehen aus den ganzen äh und Beteiligungen ähm ziehen die sich raus. So, das heißt, da werden jetzt auch die Ölfelder nicht weiter äh entwickelt. Da da fehlt Massiv Kohle.
Und natürlich auch Know-How und Connection und so weiter, dass wenn die Russen nicht so ohne Weiteres ersetzen können und da sie halt auch die ganzen Technologie überhaupt nicht mehr gewartet und äh upgegradet bekommen, ist das halt alles
alles so potenziell kurz vor dem Kollaps in absehbarer Zeit merkt man zum Beispiel auch bei den Flugzeugen.
Ähm ich habe Schätzungen gelesen, dass ungefähr die Hälfte aller.
Na zunächst mal die Flotte ist in den letzten zwanzig, 30 Jahren zunehmend verwestlicht worden. Das heißt, da kommt sehr viel Airbus, Boeing und so weiter zum Einsatz, wie ja auch sonst überall auf der Welt.
Klar, so ein paar russische Flugzeuge werden sie sicherlich auch noch äh haben und weiß nicht, was sie noch gesaust haben, aber äh.
Internationalen Bereich, ist ja so ein bisschen wie mit Google und Apple beim Smartphone hast du halt irgendwie Airbus und Boeing äh beim beim Flugzeug und so ein Flugzeug hängt natürlich eine ganze Menge dran. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo sie jetzt keine Teile mehr bekommen, können sie halt Flugzeuge nicht mehr richtig warten.
Kriegen halt die Teile nicht. Das heißt, da müssen sie andere Flugzeuge aus dem Betrieb rausnehmen.
Um äh die dann irgendwie reparieren zu können und die werden dann trotzdem irgendwann kaputt gehen.
Es ist sogar noch krasser. Es ist sogar noch eine Nummer krasser. Also erstmal
äh gehört Ihnen die Hälfte der Flugzeuge gar nicht
sondern die gehört halt ich glaube einer irischen oder also bei Aeroflot zum Beispiel ist es so, dass die Hälfte äh der ähm der der flotte von Eirot
ja in der westlichen Leasinggesellschaft äh gehört.
Alle wieder zurückgefordert.
Die halt genau, die halt jetzt auch gekündigt hat und in den Verträgen steht irgendwie, dass sie jetzt innerhalb von 30 Tagen ähäh erstmal airoflot die Hälfte ihrer Flugzeuge oder ja die Hälfte ihrer Flugzeuge zurückgeben müssen.
Das wird auch noch interessant, wie das in der Praxis dann äh abläuft. Des Weiteren äh liegt der
Hauptwartungsstützpunkt für Aeroflot äh liegt in Deutschland. Das heißt ja das heißt,
sagen, wenn die ihre Flugzeuge überholen lassen wollen,
äh die haben gar nicht die haben nicht mal die Werkstätten in Russland, sondern die haben die bisher halt immer irgendwie im Westen hauptsächlich nach Deutschland, wie gesagt, bei Ayro flott geflogen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Leipzig oder irgendwo in der Ecke, aber jedenfalls,
ja
ähm äh können Sie halt die Wartung gar nicht mehr durchführen lassen. Mein kleinere Arbeiten werden sie irgendwo noch machen können
aber eben äh dann natürlich Ersatzteile äh laufen halt halt auch aus äh dort. Das heißt
äh ja. Ähm wie gesagt, Hälfte der Flugzeuge zurückgegeben, wobei man sagen können, okay, vielleicht ist das gar nicht so schlimm. Da sparen sie halt dann ein bisschen Geld.
So
aber äh die andere Hälfte kann eben auch nicht weiter äh fliegen, weil äh die nicht gewartet äh werden kann und dann äh so nach und nach klar, ein bisschen kann man das überziehen und so und die Russen sind da wahrscheinlich auch nicht so ganz so.
Aber äh ja es gibt es gibt halt
einfach Grenzen. So wenn bestimmte Dinge dann ausfallen Elektronik äh oder Verschleißteile oder so, dann äh ja kannst du die Dinger einfach nicht mehr nicht mehr wirklich
Fliegen und das ist natürlich in so einem großen Land wie Russland äh kann das natürlich auch nochmal richtig ein Problem werden. So,
Sagen OK Russland hat halt ja auch so zwei eigene äh Verkehrsflugzeug.
Jetzt entwickelt, stellt sich aber raus, das Problem ist bei dem einen kommen die Triebwerke halt von Roys Reus glaube ich. Das heißt.
Auch da, klar, ist super und sie könnten zwar theoretisch, also es gibt da wohl auch eine russische Triebwerksentwicklung, aber das dauert wohl noch drei Jahre, bis das bis das zertifiziert ist.
Also können Sie selbst ihre eigenen russischen Verkehrsflugzeuge nicht nicht äh äh wirklich fliegen und Sie beziehungsweise haben Sie dann noch einen einen weiteres, was tatsächlich mit russischen Triebwerken fliegt?
Aber ähm die Innereien von den Triebwerken
kommen auch aus dem Westen. Ja, das heißt, sie können jetzt auch keine sozusagen selbst für ihre eigenen Triebwerke äh fehlen ihnen die Teile, um die jetzt äh fertig zu bauen und und das Know-how.
Ja ähm das ist also das ist halt jetzt das das könnte halt richtig ein Desaster äh werden, weil
ja wenn
plötzlich in einem in einem Land wie Russland, wo du wirklich signifikante Entfernungen hast und wo alleine nur um die Wirtschaft am Laufen zeigt, müssen die Leute schon auch noch hier hin und her fliegen und Zeugs transportieren und so und wenn den dann innerhalb jetzt, wenn der sich das über mehrere Monate hinziehen
sollte
äh kommt ein Großteil der russischen Wirtschaft allein nur zum Erliegen, weil äh ja oder wird alles extrem teurer, weil die dann nur noch irgendwie die Sachen mit dem Zug transportieren können und
nicht mehr nicht mehr fliegen.
Also das ist wirklich ein ein ein Rezept für das totale äh Wirtschaftsdesaster. Man sieht das jetzt auch schon so an der Börse. Äh die russische Börse ist seit,
Beginn geschlossen
Da traut man sich gar nicht mehr den Betrieb aufzumachen, weil wahrscheinlich alles sofort äh bei null wäre und alles, was so international äh gehandelt wird, das das das geht schon irgendwie enorm in die Knie. Niemand hat mehr überhaupt irgendein Incentive so. Alle wollen nur noch äh äh weg und alle wollen sagen nur noch
und alle ziehen ihre Kohle raus. Wobei grade das äh noch mal ein sehr interessanter Punkt ist, weil alle, die jetzt in Russland investiert haben und diese Investments jetzt abziehen wollen.
Lässt Russland nicht, sondern wir haben gleich so ein Gesetz erlassen, so ja nee, ihr müsst die Kohle jetzt hier behalten.
Ja, klingt jetzt erstmal wie so ein Rettungsanker, ist aber natürlich dann der Garant dafür, dass,
selbst wenn sie jetzt morgen mit den Kampfhandlungen aufhören.
Selbst wenn sie irgendwie die die Blümchen in die Hand machen so ah nee war alles nur Spaß und so weiter wir fahren jetzt wieder mal zurück. Macht ihr mal weiter irgendwie alles gut.
Vertrauen von Investment äh Firmen aller Art ja in Russland, das ist halt jetzt.
Komplett im Eimer. Niemand steckt seine Kohle rein, so ein Land, was so eben mal so zwischendurch so, weil, ja, wenn dir sorry, wir müssen jetzt grad mal ein Land überfallen. Irgendwie, ach so, ihr habt da wirtschaftliche Probleme, an die die Kohle bleibt hier.
Dass es irgendwie so nicht so das Umfeld äh in dem man sich gerne so bewegen möchte und
Mudis und wie heißt dieser andere Rating-Agentur, hat jetzt innerhalb weniger Tage Russland irgendwie auf den aller niedrigsten Level runter äh gevotet, der nur irgendwie geht, der ist irgendwie CCC Minus oder so. Danach ist irgendwie quasi Insolvenz.
Sprich, die können auch keine Kredite aufnehmen. Niemand wird denen irgendwie Kohle geben und wenn, dann wird's so vollkommen irrwitzigen äh Zinsen, die entweder Russland nicht zu bezahlen ähm bereit ist und wahrscheinlich auch kein Unternehmen dann auch noch
den Glauben hat, dass sie das
bekommen. Also sie können kein Geld aufnehmen, sie können ihre Reserven nicht zum Einsatz bringen, ihre Wirtschaft geht grade äh den Bach runter, damit sinken natürlich auch die Steuereinnahmen, die Leute werden arbeitslos
es kommt einfach keine Kohle rein und das ist halt dieser typische kapitalistische Zyklus, wenn's erstmal scheiße läuft, dann läuft's halt auch immer schneller Scheiße.
Dazu veraltet ihr ganzes,
äh ihren Flugpark, wenn der erstmal irgendwie äh gegroundet ist, dann läuft halt auch überhaupt nix mehr in der Wirtschaft, dann kannst du auch irgendwann diese Flugzeuge wegschmeißen, weil die gehen halt im Wesentlichen durch Nichtbenutzung auch einfach äh kaputt, es sei denn du parkst die da irgendwie schön in Spanien.
Und ähm.
Dann werden sich natürlich auch viele Leute äh in Russland fragen so, äh hallo, ich habe hier nichts mehr zu tun, ich verdiene hier keine Kohle mehr, es gibt kein Geld. Äh das Geld, was ich habe, ist nix mehr wert.
Bin hier in hochqualifizierter äh Mitarbeiter. Was was geht? Die werden sich doch auch denken, ja äh.
Ne dann dann verlassen die dann halt äh das Land. Und was mich völlig, was mich völlig, was mich völlig, wirklich, völlig weggehauen hat, ist
dass dieser Wahnsinn jetzt in Russland äh so weit geht, dass sie also wirklich auch noch ihre Kronjuwelen auch gleich noch hinterher schmeißen. Putin hat ja schon vor ein paar Jahren diesen vollkommenen Putinspinner
also Putinfreundner äh ist gerade wieder vergessen. Also der quasi äh Chef von Roskosmos geworden ist, ja,
dessen Qualität, Freund von Putin ist und nicht ich kenne mich mit Raumfahrt aus. Der in den letzten Jahren sowieso schon negativ aufgefallen ist und der hat halt jetzt.
Natürlich die auf die ganzen Embargos auch krass reagiert,
Gab's ja hier äh sollte in den nächsten Tagen sollte äh Satelliten starten,
Da kamen sie dann auf die geile Idee, dass One-Wap dann erst mal zusagen soll, ja, äh sie dürfen aber jetzt keine militärischen Anwendungen irgendwie hochfliegen und.
Welche Forderungen gestellt und so und wollen wir halt einfach nur gesagt, irgendwie fickt euch. Äh wir ziehen jetzt hier äh ab. Die Kooperation mit.
Der Isar ist beendet. Die Isar.
Hatte in Koro einen dritten Startplatz gebaut, extra nur für Sojus-Raketen. Russland hat in den letzten Jahren Sojus-Raketen, die von dort starten können, entwickelt. Hatte dort unten ein Team. Das Team ist komplett abgezogen worden.
Da ist jetzt nix mehr los, da findet keinerlei Sojus-Lounge äh statt. Das betrifft unter anderem diese Galileosatelliten, das Navigationssystem der EU.
Äh was unter anderem mit diesen Raketen geflogen werden kann. Gut, da können sie halt irgendwie jetzt auf Ariana Raketen umschwenken und so weiter, aber ist auf jeden Fall eine eine äh
eine wirtschaftliche, technische, zeitliche äh Disruption, aber ist natürlich auch eine Disruption des Selbstverständnisses des europäischen ähm.
Raumfahrtstandorts, weil die Europäer, die haben immer für sich zugute gehalten, dass sie die einzigen sind, die mit allen können.
Ja, die können mit den Russen, die können mit den Chinesen, die können mit den Amerikanern, die können irgendwie auch mit dem Rest der Welt. Alle anderen können mit irgendjemanden nicht,
Und grade diese Kooperation mit den Russen war natürlich immer irgendwie was Besonderes, ne, weil es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die Russen da.
Keine Erfahrung haben in diesem Bereich oder so, ne? Sondern
da ist ist sehr viel Know-How, da ist sehr viel Kompetenz drin und Raumfahrt ist halt auch wichtig, nicht nur weil es halt eine Einnahmequelle ist über die Starts von kommerziellen äh Satelliten et cetera, sondern es ist halt auch einfach ein Technologie.
Ähm Pionier Ding, was einfach so eine Wirtschaft nach vorne bringt. Ja, Deutschland.
Europa investiert ja in Raumfahrt nicht, weil's so schön ist irgendwie Fernsehsoliten hochzuschießen, sondern weil das ja auch einfach.
Die Forschung, die dauerhafte Entwicklung dieser Technologie permanent einfach das Geld, was du da reinsteckst, das das das pumpst du halt,
dreifach und vierfach und fünffach wieder in die in die Wirtschaft mit äh rein, über technologische äh Errungenschaften, Turnierleistungen, äh First Prototypen et cetera PP.
Das ist natürlich etwas, was jetzt Russland quasi auch nochmal soeben aufgibt
auch jetzt bei Ross Kosmos halt einfach auch in in der Führung und so einen so einen totalen Putin Lunatic
drin haben. Also wenn das jetzt irgend so ein etablierter äh Raumfahrt-Typ wäre, der jetzt irgendwie so hm ja, das ist aber jetzt nicht so gut, wie er das jetzt gerade macht, sondern nein, nein, der poltert gleich noch.
Und träumt davon jetzt irgendwie die ganzen Raketen, den Interpret in den Tal äh Raketen für Nuklearsprengstoffe zu verwandeln. Also da da läuft schon wirklich alles schief, was nur in irgendeiner Form
schief laufen kann, aber das muss man sich halt fragen wie lange kann das,
gut gehen und was genau passiert eigentlich, wenn das dann nicht mehr gut geht, weil es ist absehbar, dass also
kurzfristig schon sehr viel Schaden erzielt wird, mittelfristig
die Situation katastrophal ist und langfristig kann sich das Land das äh alleine nicht leisten. Irgendwann werden sie auch nicht mehr in der Lage sein Öl und Gas zu verkaufen, wenn sie keine äh Ersatzteile und Technologie zu bekommen.
Und dann genau und dann haben wir noch den dritten äh Bereich äh nämlich äh ja Mikroprozessoren,
Chips. Ähm und da sieht es so aus. Ähm.
Russland und Weißrussland ähm so haben
versucht in den letzten äh eigentlich ja in den letzten Dekaden, aber auch natürlich jetzt nochmal in den letzten zehn Jahren auch im Sinne von irgendwie mehr Chip-Autonomie äh äh zu bekommen, haben halt versucht
eigene inländische Chip-Produktion
aufzubauen beziehungsweise die vorhandenen äh vorhandene Chip äh Produktion entsprechend äh ja nach vorne zu bringen. So.
Aber ähm sie sind jetzt im Grunde genommen, also die beste russische äh Chipfabrik.
Jetzt bei 90 Nanometer Notes.
Das ist ungefähr das äh so äh was äh ja im Westen beziehungsweise hauptsächlich in Asien eigentlich muss man sagen im im fernen Osten.
So was wir halt so zweitausendfünf ungefähr äh war glaube ich so weiß nicht, Pension vier oder so was war war in der in der Kategorie.
Oder der Pension Duo das ist glaub ich irgendwie so neunzig.
Und sie haben versucht halt dann jetzt wenigstens auf 65 Nanometer zu gehen, aber da scheitern sie jetzt seit Jahren schon.
Dran, also die 65 Nanometer haben sie nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt
und äh ansonsten ist das Level, also was sie hinkriegen, so was die russischen Chipfirmen hauptsächlich machen, sind halt so RFID-Karten, SIM-Karten so diese diese Kategorie
da sind sie einige.
Einigermaßen ja äh self äh sustain und wahrscheinlich auch für so antike Waffensysteme und so ähm reicht es das auch.
Alles alles aus, aber äh ich meine, aktuell sind glaube ich also sind wir glaube ich bei fünf Nanometer äh äh gerade so, dass es das ist das.
Ja und drei Nanometer ist so Ante Porters.
Und ähm und jetzt man gesagt, okay äh.
Äh da könnten dann vielleicht die Chinesen einspringen, aber äh tatsächlich sind die Chinesen selber
auch nicht wirklich so weit. Also
die Chinesen haben glaube ich sind maximal irgendwo bei 30 Nanometer im Moment aber auch nicht so na ja mit so,
nicht so tollen Yals und
Ähm da ist es jetzt so, dass weil eben jetzt die reine Chip-Fabrikation so in Russland nicht möglich ist äh sind eben
viele auch jetzt äh äh russische Firmen, die jetzt,
Entwicklung haben oder Chips brauchen, äh sind halt Fapples gegangen. Das heißt, die haben halt Designs gemacht, die dann halt bei TSNC zum Beispiel in Taiwan äh äh dann gefertigt wurden. Davon sind's jetzt
auch abgeschnitten.
Und da kann eben können aber auch die Chinesen nicht wirklich einspringen plus dass sie auch nicht die Kapazitäten haben plus dass natürlich jetzt
auch noch in den letzten Jahren so die,
schottet in der Automobilindustrie äh auch dazu geführt hat, dass sie ihre neuen Fertigungsaufträge nicht nicht durchgekriegt.
Haben äh dort ähm so was was halt heißt, äh dass ihnen jetzt schlichtweg äh ja die Prozessoren also Laptops, Server und so weiter, da kommt jetzt nix mehr nach.
So und ähm klar, kannst du auch fünf oder zehn Jahre betreiben jetzt noch die Systeme, aber wenn die jetzt irgendwie neue Server brauchen oder so äh ja dann ist Nini halt äh rüberschmuggeln.
Noch nicht mal mehr Bitcoin meinen.
Ja. Also selbst da äh wird's wird's dann.
Wird's dann äh eng äh werden und was halt dazu führen wird, ich ich meine sowieso in Russland ist der Automatisierungsgrad die Zahl der Industrieroboter und so ist ist unter dem Weltdurchschnitt,
das will will was heißen. Also die sind also Russland ist da,
jetzt was so Automatisierung und Digitalisierung angeht nicht nicht wirklich weit.
Nach vorne gekommen beziehungsweise wenn dann eben mit Hilfe des Westens und dann ging ja schon der Spruch rum passt auf euer iPhone auf, es könnte das Letzte sein.
Ja
Zumal ja Apple auch den Verkauf komplett eingestellt hat.
Auch ein ziemlich bemerkenswerter äh Move war, ne? Also es kam so Forderungen so, ja, mach den App Store dicht und so weiter und Apple so, in dem Fall verkaufen einfach überhaupt nix mehr. Lassen einiges den App Store laufen, was ich auch okay finde, weil
ich meine, da hängt ja auch sehr viel anderes dran und man muss auch mal sehen, gerade Smartphone-Infrastruktur, das ist natürlich dann auch für die Bürger relevant, die jetzt vielleicht mal äh.
Nicht unbedingt jetzt so Putin konform sind. Trotzdem, also dadurch, dass alle Zahlungssysteme weggebrochen sind, funktioniert natürlich auch diese ganze Smartphone-Infrastruktur
nur noch so begrenzt. Äh Kreditkarten können nicht mehr benutzt werden. Apple Pay, Google Pay, das funktioniert alles nicht mehr.
Gibt's lange äh Schlangen jetzt in der Metro. Also das wird jetzt alles sehr schnell
spürbar werden für die Bevölkerung, für die Wirtschaft und damit natürlich auch Fragen aufwerfen. Es gibt ja auch schon erste russische Unternehmen, die tatsächlich sich jetzt irgendwie hingestellt haben und gesagt haben, so Leute, so geht das nicht, ne? Luke oy zum Beispiel.
Ist ein russisches Unternehmen, die zwar auch in äh ich glaube in London eine.
Wesentlich sogar von dort aus agieren, aber ein russisches Unternehmen sind aber ein privates, das also nicht dem Staat gehört, wie die allermeisten anderen, so wie
und so weiter und die haben halt gesagt, so geht's nicht äh weiter. Lass das äh sein. Nicht, dass ich jetzt denke, dass das jetzt irgendwie eine große Wirkung haben wird, wenn die sich jetzt äußern, weil in dem Modus sind wir jetzt irgendwie noch nicht, nur sehe ich halt grade eine,
Tonne an Eskalationspotential, nur fehlt mir jetzt so ein bisschen die Kraft, mir vorzustellen, wie.
Beschissen das eigentlich alles mittlerweile äh ist in diesem Putin-Staat und inwiefern die eigentlich.
Überhaupt die Einschläge im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes noch noch merken.
Und ja mal gucken. Ich meine gut ich meine auf der anderen Seite haben die Russen natürlich.
Harte Zeiten alle erlebt und überlebt, also speziell.
In der äh Zeit ist in einigen Gegenden war tatsächlich der Hunger,
Russland zurückgekehrt. Ja, da haben Leute wirklich gehungert. So in den in den Neunzigern.
Und äh insofern äh sind sie da glaube ich jetzt äh durchaus ein bisschen.
Weiter und resistenter auf der anderen Seite sind natürlich die Erwartungen und die Ansprüche jetzt auch ganz andere.
Und äh damals äh war das auch eine ganz anders, ich sage mal.
Gesteuerte äh oder kontrollierte Gesellschaft äh und äh ja jetzt jetzt haben die Leute halt sich natürlich schon dran gewöhnt
an an einen gewissen Luxus und anderen gewissen Standard und.
Eben aber auch die wirtschaftlichen Verflechtungen äh äh wie gesagt, um nach vorne zu kommen. Ich meine, was halt das mit den Chips und den Flugzeugen halt ganz gut zeigt, ist, es gibt halt,
bestimmte Hochtechnologie, die es so spezialisiert, dass da wirklich nur ein, zwei Länder überhaupt,
äh äh ja in der Lage sind bestimmte Produkte oder Komponenten zu fertigen und das selbst ein Land wie Russland.
Selbst mit jahrelangen Anstrengungen und hohen Investitionen, also was sie in ihre Chip-Fabriken halt gesteckt haben. Das waren Milliarden und es ist alles, aber die sie haben dann alle äh teilweise auch äh ja.
Ihr Pleite gemacht, weil sie natürlich auch einfach kein vernünftiges Geschäftsmodell gefunden haben. Ich meine, selbst wenn du meine Russland hat halt, was weiß ich, eine Milliarde allein in die 90 Nanometerproduktion gesteckt,
aber
ähm der der Markt äh der Weltmarkt oder auch überhaupt der Markt für neunzig nanometer Chips ist halt äh deutlich begrenzt ja. Da kannst du halt kein vernünftiges Geschäftsmodell äh äh drauf auf,
bauen, weil die Kosten äh sind halt vergleichbar. Na ja und zu China noch.
Auch warum China auch nicht einspringen kann, ist, dass wiederum China die Lithographie-Maschinen
äh nicht selber äh bauen kann, sondern die kommen halt äh aus Holland und aus Deutschland hauptsächlich äh so. Von äh äh Jenoptik beziehungsweise äh.
Ist äh andere Dinge. Es ist so der der weltgrößte Hersteller von Lithographie-Maschinen. Und,
äh die äh liefern die halt auch nicht nach China so. Das heißt auch China kann nicht beziehungsweise auch wieder Ersatzteile und Wartung äh und so, das heißt wenn die Chinesen jetzt anfangen würden also ja
jetzt zu sagen stellvertretend für Russland irgendwie was produzieren zu wollen ja und.
Das ist halt das Ding. Du kannst dich halt, wenn du heute in der Welt mithalten willst, ist die Wirtschaft so miteinander verflochten.
Kannst du dich da nicht einfach rausziehen und wenn du da wenn da wenn du davon abgeschnitten wirst äh jetzt plötzlich,
geht halt so viel so viel an das Turnier gedacht hat, das hört halt plötzlich auf zu funktionieren. Ähm so und.
Weil alles, weil alles von von allem abhängt. Ich habe ja auch gestern mit mit Lino schon kurz äh Netzposition drüber gesprochen und dann war das dann halt auch so wirklich dann die Frage im Raum so.
Ist es denn jetzt überhaupt vorstellbar, ne? Wir hatten ja vorhin die möglichen Szenarien eines Exits, ne und äh.
Dieses eine Ding mit.
Sind wir in der Lage einerseits durch die hintenrum Unterstützung der Ukraine und deren hoher Motivation den Widerstand zu leisten in der Lage den.
Tierischen Vormarsch, zumindest soweit noch in Grenzen zu halten, dass irgendwie det Land nicht komplett platt gemacht wird auf der einen Seite.
Und andererseits äh politisch und in dem Fall halt vor allem wirtschaftspolitisch durch diese Sanktion so viel Druck zu erzeugen.
Entweder Putin selber irgendwie zu Sinnen kommt oder am Ende irgendwie.
Will jetzt keinen Volksaufstand daherreden, das erscheint mir doch sehr unwahrscheinlich, aber alles erscheint einem in diesem gesamten Szenario ja sehr unwahrscheinlich. Ähm.
Dass sie sich einfach.
Faktisch ähm quasi umorientieren müssen, weil sie einfach gar nicht mehr anders können. Also weil sonst einfach nichts mehr funktioniert.
So gar nichts mehr funktionieren.
Irgendwann ist ja auch Schluss und dann kehrt auch irgendwann der Hunger wieder zurück. So also das ist ja jetzt ordentlich komplett ausgeschlossen. Wenn du auf einmal nicht mehr in der Lage bist.
Zu fliegen irgendwie deine Landmaschinen äh zu reparieren, überhaupt irgendwas Technologisches am Laufen zu halten.
Innerhalb von Wochen, Monaten und Jahren äh zusammen. Die Frage ist nur, in welchen Zeiträumen wird es unerträglich und hat es noch Relevanz für diesen Konflikt.
Allein ja allein auch jetzt, dass er sich selbst die Gas- oder Ölförderung, weil,
wie bringst du da dann jetzt die Ersatzteile, was weiß ich, äh die du natürlich auch brauchst für deine Fördereinrichtungen und und Ölbohrungen und für den Pipeline-Betrieb und so.
Werden Sie wahrscheinlich noch noch irgendwie hinkriegen und was halt.
Auch der der der Fall äh ist, ist das schon normalerweise jetzt, ich sage mal, Sicherheitsbewegungen äh in der Regel äh,
wirtschaftliche Überlegungen äh ja äh in in in solchen äh Regimen einfach übertrumpfen.
So, das heißt äh ja ähm bevor er äh also.
Lieber hungern als sterben ja so ist dann dann die die Denke äh äh quasi ähm und äh ja in insofern ist ist die Frage,
die Russen sind wie gesagt auch bis zu einem gewissen Grad leidensfähig auf der anderen Seite. Äh wie wir ja bei Yell ziehen,
gesehen haben, so wenn das mit der Wirtschaft irgendwie kacke läuft und plötzlich äh du einen Haufen Arbeitslose hast und ich weiß auch nicht, wie.
Toll das Sozialsystem äh in in Russland äh ist, aber äh ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt,
überwältigend oder oder großartig ist ähm und ja
da gibt's halt eben auch gewisse Grenzen beziehungsweise würde das dann bedeuten äh dass du auch nochmal äh deine wie's so schön heißt Kontroll- und Erzwingungskosten.
Ähm äh in die Höhe schießen, äh weil du halt
äh dann Leute und Proteste unterdrücken äh musste und das ist halt der Vorteil halt von Demokratien, dass du äh ja einen niedrigere Kontroll und Erzwingungskosten
hast und plus intrinsische Motivation führt halt auch zu höherer Produktivität als wenn die Leute dann zu irgendwas.
Was zwingst. Ja also eigentlich ist jetzt schon.
So viel in den Brunnen äh äh gefallen, habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich mir auch gar nicht richtig vorstellen kann, äh wie äh das Ganze so schnell ähm wieder
ja wie Russland so schnell wieder auf einen grünen Zweig kommen sollte.
Weil natürlich jetzt auch das Misstrauen da ist und äh es ist auch so schön so äh Vertrauen aufzubauen dauernd halt viele viele Jahre
Aber äh um das zu zerstören äh reicht halt eine Minute oder wie in dem Fall ein, zwei Tage äh Invasion und äh ja.
War's das erstmal wieder für eine Dekade.
Ja, dann war's das für eine Dekade oder zwei oder drei äh das das einzige ja, aber wie gesagt, das ist halt sehr unwahrscheinlich, weil
Russland hat halt einfach auch nicht die Institutionen und nicht die Kultur ähm dass äh da jetzt eine demokratische Revolution auf einmal statt,
befinden würde. Selbst das würde nicht wirklich funktionieren und ähm gut,
äh wie es sein könnte, ist, dass das irgendjemand auf die Idee kommt, Putin
wegzuräumen, deswegen ähm hm sitzt da jetzt auch immer an zunehmend längeren Tischen so.
Ich dachte zuerst, als ich es gesehen habe, mit Sarkosi, damals sagt die, ah ja okay, covid Vorsichtsmaßnahme so, Social Distancing.
Aber äh tatsächlich äh jetzt dann auch aus mehreren Quellen schon gehört, nee, nee, das ist nicht ist nicht Angst vor covid.
Sondern das ist halt Angst äh vor einem Attentat äh äh durch seine eigenen Leute. Deswegen sitzen die halt.
Alle äh jetzt zehn oder 15 Meter äh weiter weg. Ja.
Angst vor den Assassinden, ja.
Und ich meine, klar, wenn du halt äh Leute in die Welt losschickst, die mit radioaktivem Polonium und mit Nowitschok und keine Ahnung was
äh äh töten, dann hast du natürlich auch die entsprechende Fantasie
dass äh ja auch jemand aus dem eigenen Apparat äh der ja Zugriff
auf äh diesen diese ganzen Giftschränke äh hat auch auf die Idee kommt, so äh Putin in die Hand zu schütteln und dann äh ich sage mal einen kleinen Tropfen,
ja von irgendeinem Nervengift. Äh da reichen ja ein paar paar Milligramm oder.
Oder ihn anzuhauchen, keine Ahnung äh mit irgendwas äh so.
Er ist wirklich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes von seiner Umwelt isoliert. So und
gibt sich äh wirklich nur noch mit den treuesten der Treuen, das heißt das sind alles Leute, die so viel zu verlieren haben, wenn er geht. Das ist für sie wie ein kleiner Tod wäre.
Und dementsprechend ähm ne äh am Ende äh lieber mit ihm untergehen, also das hat und das war schon beim.
Vergleich so also ich muss die ganze Zeit an diesen Film der Untergang denken.
Mhm, mhm.
Gut, er macht vielleicht jetzt noch nicht so einen verwirrten Eindruck, aber ähm alle, die mit ihm gesprochen haben, meinen ja auch, äh wer jetzt sagen wir mal so mit der Realität jetzt nicht mehr so auf du, ne?
Ja, ja.
Und ähm sitze dann da halt und auch diese ganze Reaktion mit was wir gewinnen nicht sofort, dann gewinnen wir halt einfach, indem wir alles kaputt schießen und mir doch egal wie viele russische Soldaten dabei sterben.
Wie viel ukrainische Soldaten und Zivilisten dabei sterben, wie viel ähm ja Vergangenheit, Geschichte, äh Infrastruktur, ähm,
von Menschen zerstört wird.
Ja, ich meine, was hing, glaube ich, was ihm schon wichtig ist, das sieht man ja, ist sagen die Zustimmung äh der Russen zu seiner Politik. Also das ist das ist ihm.
Das ist ihm schon im Großen und Ganzen wichtig. Wie gesagt, selbst also bei 65Prozent hat er halt schon Panik gekriegt. Eigentlich
erwartet er, dass das ganze Land irgendwie hinter ihm steht und achtzig, 90 Prozent Zustimmung, so sein äh sein Ziel und das ist ihm bisher auch auch ganz gut gelungen so, auch mit Hilfe von Propaganda.
Aber das kann natürlich also Propaganda bringt dich halt nur so und so weit, wenn das dann anfängt irgendwann zu kippen und.
Dann ist es ja auch so, dass dass äh die mediale Kontrolle äh ganz so vollständig nicht mehr ist, sondern die Dinger verbreiten sich ja dann dann schon.
Äh nach und nach und die haben ja auch soziale Netzwerke und die haben ja in in Russland
längst nicht äh diese Zensur oder Kontrolle wie Chinasee sie etwa ausübt
aber ja also Putin äh ich hatte heute Nacht einen Putin Albtraum. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich dir davor habe ich hier.
Hast im Internet davon.
Also na ja also äh ja es war wirklich das war wirklich krass vor allen Dingen ähm,
Habe ich selten auch äh sagen so geträumt, wo ich einerseits visuell was sehe und gleichzeitig auch noch geträumt habe, was ich dann darüber denke, was ich gerade sehe so. Und jedenfalls fand ich mich
irgendwie mit Putin auf einmal in einem Auto wieder, also fuhr mit ihm.
In einem Auto und äh ja guckte dann so und dann dachte ich mir, hm, also.
Ist das wirklich jetzt jetzt Putin? Also ist die Situation war die, dass es dass es schon irgendwie Putin sein sollte, warum auch immer. Keine Ahnung, ging jedenfalls da los so. Und dann dachte ich mir, aber Moment mal.
Also es sieht nicht ganz so aus wie Putin. Es ist vielleicht ein Double so, weil irgendwie ja und
Außerdem dachte ich mir und wieso sitzt der denn jetzt so nahezu neben mir, wo er sonst immer zehn Meter Abstand hält so, ne.
Kann nicht wirklich Putin sein so das muss ein Double sein, dachte ich mir und dann dachte ich mir aber wie sage ich's ihnen jetzt, weil vielleicht
ja tue ich ihm ja dann doch Unrecht. Also ich äh aber ich habe dann äh ihm ihn gefragt im Traum sie sind nicht wirklich Putin oder so und dann
drehte er sich im Traum zum.
Zu mir so, lehnt sich rüber, guckt mir in die Augen und sagt dann, ich hatte doch gleich gespürt, dass wir eine besondere Verbindung zueinander haben. Ja.
Es ist so.
Und.
Und dann dann dachte ich mir noch irgendwie, what the fuck, also jetzt besucht mich Putin persönlich im Traum, ist aber zu feige selber zu kommen, sondern schickt einen Double, was sich dann auch noch mit mir anfreunden will. So.
Ja. Also das war das war wirklich äh.
Der Verdacht gekommen, dass du dich vielleicht mit dem Thema schon zu sehr beschäftigt hast in dieser ersten Woche.
Ja, ich dachte dann auch äh irgendwie vielleicht habe ich irgendwie äh ja ähm keine Ahnung ähm.
Kann kann gut sein, zumal ich auch äh mir neulich mal angeguckt hatte, weil war jemand meinte, er.
Hätte doch äh äh doch sehr zugenommen ähm an an an Gewicht zugelegt, hatte ich mir dann tatsächlich mal
auch so Bilder äh von den letzten zehn, 15 Jahren angeguckt äh zum Glück das Netz ist ja voll mit
Putin-Bildern und da kann man halt ganz schön gucken, eigentlich fast von Jahr zu Jahr oder so, wie er sich, wie er sich verändert hat und äh ja, hat auch das Gefühl, dass da vielleicht ein Covid-Koller
äh äh hat äh irgendwie oder dass das auch irgendwie diese Pandemie nicht spurlos an ihm vorübergegangen ist, aber,
Ja, wer weiß, vielleicht war's ja auch nicht nicht wirklich die Pandemie. Ja.
Was haben wir noch? Also wir sind jetzt schon schon ganz ganz gut ganz gut durch eigentlich durch durch unsere.
Würde ich auch meinen. Also das war jetzt auch so ein bisschen der Versuch, mal.
Erstmal so alles so aufzuwischen, was jetzt so unmittelbar rumliegt und äh mal so alles so ein wenig zu kontextualisieren, was jetzt eigentlich grade passiert ist. Ähm eben so mit dieser.
Zielsetzung, dass man dann äh jetzt in irgendeinem irgendeiner Regelmäßigkeit hier äh eine weitere Betrachtung machen kann.
Ich würde mal Deutschland.
Jetzt in diesem ganzen Reaktionsgewitter auch nochmal kurz beleuchten. Da kann man sich jetzt bestimmt auch nochmal vier Stunden drüber unterhalten, aber nur, dass wir das nochmal mit reingenommen haben.
Vorher aber vielleicht noch kurz der Hinweis, es gibt ja noch so einen.
Anderen Störfaktor, aber wir haben im Prinzip schon knapp angesprochen gerade, aber nicht so richtig in den Mittelpunkt gestellt, aber das ist natürlich auch äh in diesem ganzen Beziehungsgeflecht zwischen Russland und Europa jetzt ein echtes Problem,
Weißt du worauf ich hinaus will?
Nein, China.
Dieses Land, was ähm ja einerseits schon jetzt in diesen.
Budapester Memorandum, ne, ja, so quasi so Beistandsgarantien äh gemacht hat, zusammen mit den USA, aber jetzt irgendwie nicht so richtig sichtbar ist
und was ja mittlerweile auch aus der EU rausgetreten ist und äh all die ganzen Aktionen, die wir äh besprochen haben, sind halt im Wesentlichen äh Sanktionen der EU plus der Amerikaner.
Plus all der Länder, die unter dem Druck,
eine Reaktion abgeben zu müssen, jetzt hier auch äh Stellung bezogen haben. Dazu gehört äh überraschenderweise, ja talking about first.
Auch die Schweiz. Ja, also sogar die
Bites hat jetzt sogar so viel Druck bekommen, dass dass sie nicht einfach mal äh Business as usual machen kann, so nach dem Motto ja Kohle hier für
von von den Gaunern bitte alle hierher so, weil hier wir sind ja neutral und so, ne?
Und ähm ja aber UK bleibt halt noch außen vor.
Warum? Gut, wir sind jetzt raus aus der EU, aber sie haben ja vor allem ein extrem unrühmliches äh Beziehungsgeflecht mit.
Verschiedenen Russen aufgebaut in den letzten Jahrzehnten und ich will jetzt nicht das ganz große Fass aufmachen, aber es ist natürlich auch.
Belegt, wie groß
der Einfluss ist auf die City of London. Wie viele äh Russen in äh UK so ihr Geld parken oder da große Investitionen machen und ähm natürlich, weil der ganze Brexit.
Schon immer auch unter dem Verdacht erhebliche ähm zumindest äh Schützenhilfe zu bekommen,
Russland, ne, was damals so in den Medien abgegangen ist, in den sozialen Medien et cetera. Das ist alles auch irgendwie von Russland mitkoordiniert oder zumindest ähm flankiert worden.
Und äh die herrschende Tory-Partei steht natürlich auch äh schon seit Wochen und Monaten in äh UK in in dem
unter Anklage kann man sagen, also unter öffentlicher Debatte, äh wo denn sie nicht überall Geld aus Russland äh als Partei,
angenommen hat. Ich habe da jetzt auch nicht den totalen Überblick. Ich will nur eigentlich darauf hinweisen, erstmal die von der EU beschlossenen Sanktionen im Verhältnis zu dem, was die UK davon übernimmt, ne. Das das da gibt's ein großes Missverhältnis. Also die
das Spiel nicht mit. Zumindest spielen sie das Spiel nicht so umfangreich mit. Sie tönen natürlich groß rum, aber es ist halt auch Boris Johnson, er tönt immer rum. Das heißt halt am Ende überhaupt,
andererseits müssen sie jetzt auch feststellen, dass sie jetzt quasi bei der größten europäischen Krise seit dem zweiten Weltkrieg.
Politisch überhaupt gar keine Rolle mehr spielen. Das ist schon wirklich bemerkenswert, ja. Also wirklich die führende diplomatische Kraft.
Innerhalb der EU was so Außenpolitik betrifft, da lief immer gar nichts ohne Großbritannien, findet jetzt eigentlich nur noch so als Randerscheinung statt und ist halt eher Teil des Problems als Teil der Lösung.
Das wollte ich nur mal so kurz in den Raum,
das da wird sich sicherlich in den nächsten Wochen auch noch so das ein oder andere abzeichnen und wird auch interessant äh sein zu sehen.
Wie die ähm ja ob ob da noch irgendwas umschaltet, ob da noch irgendwas äh anderes äh stattfindet so. Wissen wir nicht, ne.
Ja, aber zurück zu Deutschland, weil es hat ja nun auch bei uns äh ein paar interessante Effekte äh gehabt.
Wenige Tage vor der Inversion sangen Deutschland sein sein Lied, was sie halt seit dem zweiten Weltkrieg äh immer gesungen haben. Wir liefern keine Waffen in äh bewaffnete Konflikte.
Weil wir sind ja total ja was eigentlich? Irgendwie pazifistisch.
Mhm. Wir mögen kein Militär mehr.
Ja und äh wir sind ja auch kein.
Kann äh wir wollen ja für niemanden mehr eine Bedrohung sein, so du hast ja vorhin auch schon ausführlich dargelegt, warum die Bundeswehr auch wirklich für niemanden eine Bedrohung sein kann.
Aber die ganze politische Grundlage und natürlich dann auch immer dieses Argument mit, na ja, grade gegenüber Russland haben wir ja so eine historische.
Schuld.
Schuld. Genau, da sind wir wieder bei der Schuldfrage. Äh so ne also so deutsche deutsche Waffen sollen irgendwie Russland nicht angehen. So dann Kriegbeginn, zwei Tage später
die Polter alles äh neu. Deutschland gibt äh die Waffen nicht nur frei im Sinne von Deutschland liefert Waffen. Nein, Deutschland äh liftet damit auch quasi eine Vertragsklausel, die sie beim Verkauf von Waffen an andere Länder hatte
die sind nämlich auch sozusagen nicht in solche Krisengebiete liefern dürfen. Das war schon immer so ein bisschen so ein Limit auf auf deutschen Waffenprodukten.
Und so durften zum Beispiel jetzt die Holländer erstmal ihre äh Raketen, die sie da aus Deutschland bekommen haben, nicht den ähm Ukrainern zur Verfügung stellen. Das
war dann irgendwann nicht mehr haltbar. Das ging dann äh relativ schnell und so ging's nebenbei ähm kam auch noch so der Beschluss, dass noch so ein Sonderetat aufgelegt wird, so ein
wie heißt das, so eine so eine.
Vermögen, ja.
Sondervermögen, äh wo mir sehr mir sehr äh,
ist die Bilanzierung da an der Stelle nicht so hundertprozentig klar, aber es ist äh sozusagen jetzt nicht einfach der normale Etat, sondern es läuft irgendwie anders. Auf jeden Fall soll halt quasi die Ausgaben für die Bundeswehr verdoppelt werden und überhaupt. Sind alle total im Alarmmodus, weil irgendwie die Russen kommen und jetzt müssen wir irgendwas tun.
Na gut.
Wie bewertest du denn so die Reaktion von Deutschland, von Scholz, von von Baerbock äh generell auf diesen Konflikt und seitdem er dann auch so richtig heiß geworden ist?
Na ja, ich sage mal, grundsätzlich äh fand ich immer äh diesen politischen Grundsatz keine Waffen in Krisengebiete zu liefern, also
im Prinzip nicht zusätzlich noch Öl ins Feuer zu gießen eigentlich ganz gut um,
so grundsätzlich, ja? Aber natürlich äh gibt es halt,
Immer wieder auch Situationen, äh wo man mit so einer Haltung äh einfach an Grenzen stößt. So das haben wir im Jugoslawien-Konflikt äh schon mal erlebt. So wo das
ähm zu einem.
Problem wurde, äh dass das Ganze wirklich durchzuhalten, weil ja auf der anderen Seite eben, wie gesagt, kann man also zugucken, äh wie Leute abgeschlachtet werden, ist jetzt
auch nicht so äh
einfach und im Grunde genommen äh ja glaube ich auch war, sagen die 5000 Helmennummer,
die man da gefahren hat äh so.
Die war echt arg peinlich, ähm.
So, die hat sich halt äh irgendwie dermaßen dann als als peinlicher Schuss in Ofen erwiesen. Da hätten sie besser einfach gesagt, nee
Wir geben Geld äh so wie auch die ich meine die Japaner haben ja noch eine eine noch krassere äh äh Friedens äh.
Policy. Die haben ja ähm in der Verfassung sogar stehen, dass sie eigentlich gar keine Streitkräfte haben dürfen.
Und so. Ja ähm und ähm ja äh aber,
Es lässt sich halt, wie man, wie man jetzt sieht, nicht nicht wirklich,
durchhalten, wenn dann solche Bilder kommen oder in in in bestimmten Situationen und die ganze Welt mitzieht und sich sich äh empört ähm so ähm ja.
Da kann man sich jetzt nicht nicht wirklich raushalten. Zu den zu den 00 Milliarden.
Hatte ich ja vorhin schon gesagt, dass.
Ähm ich ich halte sehe, dass eben das das Verteidigungsministerium, das ist halt das ist halt eine ja.
Das hatten wir ja schon. Mir geht's jetzt wirklich ein bisschen mehr um die politische Reaktion Deutschlands und äh sozusagen auf welche Rolle Deutschland jetzt innerhalb dieses Konflikts übernimmt, weil äh in gewisser Hinsicht hat sie sich ja mit dieser Entscheidung.
Sehr klar positioniert.
Aber auch aus so einer ähm ich würde sagen auch aus so einem aus so einem EU-Machtvakuum herausgeholt.
Weil das war ja immer so eine Selbstbeschränkung, so die ja auch immer irgendwie hieß, wir nehmen uns in gewisser Hinsicht solche Optionen von vornherein.
Gut man das jetzt auch immer finden mag, aber damit war dann auch irgendwie klar, dass jetzt die.
Sprache der der der Kriegsdiplomatie, wenn sie denn gesprochen werden soll aus Europa. Die kamen halt aus London und die kamen aus Paris.
Und jetzt ist London irgendwie weg und Paris kann's alleine auch nicht machen und Deutschland hat jetzt quasi sein volles Gewicht wieder.
Ob man das gut findet oder nicht, aber das ist das ist jetzt sozusagen die Achse ist irgendwie klar. Natürlich immer mit Frankreich,
zusammen und zumindest jetzt nach einer Woche bricht auch dieser ganze EU-Apparat jetzt auch nicht auseinander, weil in der Frage äh Bedrohung durch Russland
Na ja, der denkt sogar Polen und Ungarn mal irgendwie klar. Ne, das das das ist ja schon mal äh in gewisser Hinsicht auch,
beruhigend, auch wenn Sand Ungarn wieder so ja nee, aber Waffenlieferungen nicht durch unser Land und so, weil gefährlich also so ein bisschen mit Zurückhaltung ist das glaube ich schon noch zu sehen.
Ja, Ungarn hat da
bisschen Angst, weil's halt auch eine eine ungarische Minderheit in der Ukraine gibt, dass die halt darunter leiden könnte. Das haben sie zumindest die Ungarn jetzt jetzt angeführt.
Und äh ja während während die Tschechen äh da äh gehen sind da ja ein bisschen Forscher. Die haben sogar jetzt äh sagen offiziellen Gesetz verabschiedet, dass es erlaubt
Tschechen äh in der Ukraine mitzukämpfen so ja
Das ist sozusagen schon so ein halber Schritt äh quasi zum Truppenentsenden. Also wir entsenden zwar niemanden, aber wenn jetzt jemand irgendwie freiwillig kommen äh gehen will, äh so. Der nächste Schritt wäre noch
ja der kann dann auch gerne irgendwie wenn's nicht zufällig um einen Kampfpiloten handelt dem leihen wir dann auch ein Flugzeug.
Aber er ist nur privat unterwegs.
Ist aber nur privat, hat jetzt äh so, ja oder wenn wenn jemand irgendwie noch so einen gebrauchten Panzer, also ich meine ja, wir haben hier noch so einen so einen Haufen gebrauchter Panzer. Die könnt ihr euch gerne für einen einen
Euro oder für für 1tausend Kronen oder so pro Stück könnt ihr euch einen einen mitnehmen. So ja das wäre ich meine soweit ist es noch nicht aber äh,
so dass also.
Vorstellen, dass die Tschechen noch mal einen besonderen Hals haben auf auf die Russen so. Also oder es ist doch geschichtlich auch irgendwie klar.
Ja, da gibt es ist so ein bisschen schon vorbelastet so. Die Russen sind nicht so super beliebt äh wobei ähm das jetzt halt auch schon,
lange lange her ist äh und so und es auch mittlerweile ja
durchaus auch viele Freunde freundschaftliche Beziehungen gibt. Wobei ja so so Russland ist jetzt nicht das Lieblingszielland äh jetzt wo Russen unbedingt leben.
Äh wollen. Also da gibt's gewisse Vorbehalte glaube ich äh ja ähm und.
Gut außerdem äh ähm hat kein Tschechien natürlich auch ganz gut Tönen, weil es da jetzt keine direkte Grenze hat. Da hat dann jetzt noch die Slowaken
äh äh davor und äh beziehungsweise dazwischen und die Polen und so. Da kann man dann schon mal auch ein bisschen den lauten äh äh machen.
Ja äh.
Aber man hört jetzt, sagen wir mal, von Spanien und Portugal hört man jetzt nicht so viele und die haben noch mehr Länder dazwischen. Also es ist schon noch mal klar, dass die Länder äh die, sagen wir mal, dem islamischen Raum.
Zugehören, hier jetzt auch eine eine wichtige Rolle spielen, finde ich und das ist vielleicht auch das erste Mal, dass wir so eine Krise in der EU haben.
Die einfach klar äh wie soll ich das sagen? Ost ist ein ist ein Ost-Thema.
Ja, wobei die die Spanier auch mit Waffenlieferungen dabei sind, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe.
Ja klar, aber aber es ist es ist für sie also sie haben da äh kulturell nicht so viel äh äh,
drin, ja, die sind auch geschichtlich in dieser Region nicht äh eingebunden. Das ist noch weniger ihre Sprachwelt als es für uns schon äh ist. Die haben auch keinerlei islamischen
Einfluss, der irgendwie irgendeine Rolle spielen würde. Ja, also ich meine
das hält sich ja in Deutschland schon in Grenzen, aber zumindest ich lebe halt irgendwie zumindest in so einem Stand äh also wir leben in so einem Stadtteil, der halt,
Pankow irgendwie und das klingt irgendwie alles schon nach Osten. Und ähm
ne? Das das das hat Bezug. Das ist irgendwie ähm relevant. Und in dem Moment, wo jetzt die EU mal abgesehen davon ist, ist es natürlich die gesamte EU ähm.
Betrifft, die Sicherheit betrifft, Finanzen betrifft et cetera und so weiter. Das ist selbstverständlich da alle mitentscheiden müssen. Ist natürlich auch klar, die baltischen Staaten stehen hier wirklich.
Wortwörtlich in der ersten Reihe. Polen hat so seine Erfahrungen gemacht.
Russen die Tschechen haben ihre Erfahrungen gemacht, ne? Also einfach weil sie Teil des Ostblocks waren und dann eben auch nochmal diese
konkreten Probleme mit der äh Länderaufteilung, mit ähm den Interventionen auch, die die Russland äh durchgeführt hat, insbesondere dann wieder auch äh in Tschechien.
Ähm dass dass das ja einfach äh ganz anders verhaftet und dass wir sozusagen in so einer,
erstmalig würde ich sagen, seitdem die EU sich überhaupt so ost erweitert hat.
Äh quasi eine politische Situation haben, wo es klar selbstverständlich und auch geboten ist, dass diese Länder, gerade wo zwei dabei sind, mit denen wir uns gerade richtig zoffen, dass wir mit denen jetzt in irgendeiner Form.
Das Richtige tun müssen. Ja das,
das, das, das, das klar ist, dass das irgendwie auch nix ist, was so aus einer westlichen Logik heraus so ohne Weiteres gelöst werden kann, auch wenn es mit NATO und so weiter zu tun hat, aber dass das kulturell politisch.
Eigentlich wirklich ein osteuropäisches Problem ist und hier auch wirklich Osteuropa primär zum Tragen kommt und Deutschland an der Stelle natürlich auch nochmal ein ganz wichtiges Bindeglied in dieser ganzen äh Geschichte darstellt.
So sehe ich das.
Wobei ja, wobei ich glaube, äh dass das äh Russland ähm.
Da weniger Europa äh jetzt äh im im Visier hat oder als Gegner, sondern dass es mehr so einen Angriff eigentlich äh aus russischer Sicht auf die USA.
Ja klar, nee, ich meine, ich sehe das jetzt auch nicht aus dieser Perspektive von äh Russland bedroht jetzt die europäischen Länder.
Das tun sie in gewisser Hinsicht natürlich, aber.
Äh es ist ja auch klar, dass dass die Lösung für dieses Problem das wird nicht in den USA die wird nicht in den USA gefunden werden.
Na ja.
Also die USA wird da eine Rolle spielen, aber das ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass hier Europa keine Rolle spielt.
Nee, nee, also und und ich meine, das das andere Ding ist, äh dass äh ja,
ähm und sagen die die nun äh ja die die NATO äh ehemaligen Ostblockländer beziehungsweise die.
Ost-EU-Länder ähm die sind,
alle schon auch ein bisschen krasser drauf. So, die sind ähm ähm sagen auch eher ähm,
Ja äh die die sind weniger, ich sage mal weniger pazifistisch eingestellt, so so würde ich das.
Einfach mal sagen und äh durchaus auch etwas Forscher oder äh durchaus eher bereit so den Russen die die Stirn
zu bieten und die Klappe aufzumachen. So weil die haben halt
eher was eher weniger Angst vor vor Russland beziehungsweise sagen sich irgendwie nee. Also wir haben also von den Russen lassen wir uns einfach jetzt nicht nicht irgendwie
schon wieder einen sagen, dass das das wollen wir nicht. Also sie haben da bei denen kommen da teilweise,
andere Traumata hoch und da ist noch mal eine größere Entschlossenheit,
äh da dieser Aggression zu begegnen, glaube ich, auch so bei den bei den einzelnen Leuten. Äh
und äh dementsprechend das reflektiert dann natürlich auch auch die Politik äh so und so ein bisschen, weil äh so ja
Da die Leute eher drauf sind, nee, also mit den also die Russen.
Äh die Sachen mal gefälligst äh in ihrem in ihrem Land bleiben und äh
So auch bisschen vielleicht Revanche, so ein paar Revanche-Gedanken auch noch so aus den Russen dann jetzt mal zu zeigen. Äh so spielen vielleicht auch eine Rolle.
Das ist halt auch nicht ganz ungefährlich, weil ich habe mir dann auch mal ein so ein hypothetisches Szenario überlegt.
Wie das denn rechtlich ist mit diesem Artikel fünf. Ähm.
Von der NATO, äh sagen diesen Verteidigungsartikel, ähm so weil ähm.
Ich dann halt überlegte okay was jetzt wenn irgendein Land jetzt, weil es sehr hypothetisch und unwahrscheinlich, aber es passieren ja lauter irgendwie sehr unwahrscheinliche Dinge gerade, aber,
angenommen jetzt irgendein Land, weiß ich nicht, Polen oder Tschechien.
Also mit Artikel 5 mal zu dem Bündnisfall, was wir vorhin schon beschrieben haben, so einer wird angegriffen, alle sind angegriffen.
Genau, der Bündnisvereiner wird angegriffen, alle sind angegriffen. So. Ähm eigentlich gefragt, na ja ähm aber wie ist denn das jetzt angenommen ähm.
Äh ich sage mal jetzt die die die Tschechen würden jetzt Truppen in die Ukraine schicken. So äh zum zum Kämpfen dort und.
Als Antwort ähm so greift jetzt Russland Tschechien an.
Tritt dann eigentlich Artikel 5 in,
in Kraft. So oder gibt es da quasi so eine Art Provokationsverbot so nach dem Motto okay äh wenn du jemanden angreifst und der schlägt zurück, dann,
ja, dann bist du nicht der Angegriffene, sondern der Angreifer. Aber,
in dem Fall würden würden ja rein hypothetisch würden ja in der Ukraine die Truppen dort nicht Russland angreifen, sondern sie würden.
Der Ukraine helfen und die russischen Truppen haben da nichts zu suchen. Ja, das heißt, äh für den Fall würde.
Gehe ich mal davon aus, auch Artikel 5 greifen.
Ja? Nicht, dass ich glaube nicht, dass es jetzt wirklich realistisch ist, aber rein nur so, sagt hypothetisch betrachtet, äh könnte jedes Land eigentlich.
Ähm von sich aus äh dort militärisch auf ukrainischem Boden helfen, wenn es zur Hilfe gerufen wird.
Ohne dass es jetzt sozusagen von sich aus ein Angriff äh auf Russland äh durchführen würde, ja.
Nur so eine ja nur hypothetisch, aber äh wer weiß so, aber es gibt gibt in dem Sinne kein Verbot äh jetzt Truppen,
zu schicken als NATO-Land
ähm seine eigenen Truppen zu schicken, äh würde nicht bedeuten, äh dass du damit jetzt riskierst, äh dass
dass die NATO nicht zur Hilfe kommt, wenn die Russen zurückschlagen. Oder also das eigene Land angreifen. So würden natürlich jetzt nicht, wenn die wenn die.
Also.
Der Verteidigungsfall wird jetzt nicht ausgelöst, wenn jetzt russische Truppen in der Ukraine, tschechische Truppen angreifen, so. Aber äh ja, äh.
Punkt war nur, es gibt jetzt in dem Sinne äh zumindest kein vertragliches Verbot äh wie ich das sehe, dass irgendein Natoland jetzt von sich aus betruppenschickt,
in der Ukraine mitzukämpfen.
Ähm und natürlich wenn sie's so machen oder was was wahrscheinlich sowieso schon passiert ist, so wie Russland das auch gemacht hat, wo äh oder.
Gut, soweit ist es noch nicht, aber Russland hat ja selber nun auch eigene Truppen da in die Ukraine geschickt äh bei der ähm bei der Krim äh Invasion.
Ähm beziehungsweise nicht bei der Krim, sondern in den in den Ost äh Gebieten, äh die halt auch nicht offiziell russische Armee waren, sondern halt ja
wie gesagt ihre Hoheitszeichen abgeklebt hatten und dann sagen auch freiwillige waren, aber wir sind auf dem auf dem
Niveau sind wir jetzt, dass halt aus verschiedensten äh EU- oder NATO-Ländern dort Leute hingehen und gegen die russischen Truppen.
Kämpfen, mit Waffen, die von uns geliefert werden. Also wir sind im Grunde genommen schon in einem Stellvertreterkrieg drin, nur nicht mit unseren
offiziellen Streitkräften.
Der könnte sich auch noch ein bisschen ausweiten und ich glaube es gibt auch noch einen anderen Aspekt den wir vorhin in diesem ganzen militärischen ähm militärischen Aufzählungen noch nicht so
gebracht haben. Das ist natürlich die äh Amerikaner und wahrscheinlich auch andere Länder an diesem Krieg ja auch teilnehmen.
Und zwar jetzt nicht mit kampfkämpfenden Verbänden, sondern mit äh Intelligence. So.
Ja, ja, also im Moment fliegen sowieso erstens durch also die ganzen Satelliten-Assets äh und so äh die ganzen ähm.
Der ganze Funkverkehr.
Auswertung äh und ähm ja äh plus Drohnen. Keine also ich meine die die die türkischen Drohnen, äh die da jetzt die da jetzt fliegen, also es war so eine andere Überlegung.
Man man könnte das Ganze auch noch eine Nummer eskalieren, indem man jetzt nicht nur äh die die Türkei diese kleinen Drohnen äh liefert.
Sondern halt äh auch nochmal so die Nummer größer, die dann halt schon
auch dann äh eine ordentliche Munitions äh last, die dann halt auch schon mal so ein paar Tonnen äh
abwerfen äh äh könnten,
so und von wo aus die gesteuert werden, das kann man ja auch nie so genau nachvollziehen, ja. Also da gibt's viele also da gibt's viel Potenzial äh so für
schön heißt äh äh Kriegsführung, wo äh wir ja nach und nach Stück für Stück äh mehr in den Krieg direkt verwickelt sein könnten. Also da da geht noch was.
Und ich kann mir vorstellen, äh wenn wenn jetzt,
tatsächlich die Russen, so wie's ja aussieht, wenn die jetzt anfangen äh äh Städte äh mehr in Schutt und Asche äh zu legen ähm dass das dann noch mal
ja nochmal heftiger wird oder ich meine was man könnte halt auch weiß ich nicht 100 liefern.
So an an äh an die Ukraine
und äh die dann ja äh damit dann diesen 60 Kilometer Konvoi vor Kiew äh zum Beispiel eliminieren.
Ja alle alles Dinge, die jetzt äh ich sage mal nicht nicht wirklich ausgeschlossen sind.
Eskalationsmöglichkeiten.
Äh ohne äh dass das jetzt direkt äh einen ja einen Angriff äh äh wäre oder eine direkt ja äh militärischer Angriff äh.
Aber einen interessanten Punkt, ne? Und ich denke, das ist auch so ein bisschen.
Zentrum der Angst, die jetzt viele Leute auch so ähm zeigen, ne, weil so dieses so oh Gott, was passiert, wenn jetzt hier äh Russland sich.
Zu bedrängt fühlt. So nach dem Motto, hey, ich störe mich nicht, während ich hier Leute umbringe. Ähm.
Was könnte sozusagen.
Passieren und wo wo würde Russland sozusagen,
noch Eskalations
potenzial haben und wie weit würden sie's treiben? Ich meine sie, sie drohen natürlich jetzt irgendwie da mit ihrem Jahr. Wir haben ja irgendwie total nur Nuklearwaffen und was nicht alles. Das ist glaube ich vor allem alles erst mal irgendwie Gerede und solche äh Pressemitteilungen mit. Wir haben jetzt hier mal unsere.
Wie heißen diese Truppen, die immer äh die sich quasi ums Nuklearpotential kümmern.
Die Abschreckungsstreitkräfte genauso. Da gab's ja auch so äh sagen wir eine Debatte darüber, hat der jetzt atomar gedroht oder nicht, weil er ja die angeblich die Abschreckungskräfte in Alarmbereitschaft versetzt hat.
Die sind immer in Alarmbereitschaft. Das das das ist so das Wesen von Abschreckungs- äh Streitkräften. Von daher war das halt so nur Säbelrasseln.
Ja, na ja, die ja, ja, das hat auch keiner wirklich ernst genommen, also die die äh USA haben jetzt auch ihre, wie ist so schön als Nuklear-Postchar oder so, nicht erhöht, um dort
äh zu zu deeskalieren und konnten jetzt auch nicht beobachten
dass jetzt die Russen irgendwie ihre strategischen Waffen jetzt wirklich aus der Garage geholt hätten. Wenn Russen ist es ja so, dass sie von den großen Raketen
haben Sie ist nur die kleinere Zahl in Silos und die größere Zahl ist halt auf diesen großen äh so diese großen LKW, die dann irgendwo hinfahren, wo es dann bestimmte Plätze gibt, die vorbereitet,
äh sind und ähm ja die sind nicht nicht wirklich ausgerückt. So
äh und auch bei den strategischen Waffen, die muss man dann meistens betankt werden und so und das ist halt ja ähm.
Schon Probleme mit dem.
Ja ja nee nee also äh zumindest äh äh hat dieser Drohung sozusagen der Erhöhung der Alarm äh äh Bereitschaft oder so
ist jetzt nichts Sichtbares gefolgt. Also da sind jetzt keine äh sind jetzt nicht die die.
Atomwaffen aus der Garage geholt und in in in Stellung äh gebracht worden oder.
Aber was
was könnte jetzt sozusagen Eskalationspotential sein, so ne? Also jetzt greifen wir nochmal deine Idee auf mit den Grusmisals, ne? So äh die Amerikaner äh fahren jetzt einfach mal ordentlich Gier auf so, weiß nicht, wie schnell sie sowas äh machen könnten, aber wahrscheinlich wird's jetzt auch nicht so lange dauern.
Sagen wir mal, sie hätten's jetzt schon vorbereitet und morgen würde stattfinden.
Und es gibt irgendwie schon immer so einen geheimen Ausbildungsstil, von dem wir irgendwie nix wissen und in der Ukraine haben sie dann auch entsprechende Leute. Oder es geht sogar so weit, dass sie da einfach ihre Undercover-Leute haben, die das einfach steuern und dann wird das so im Namen der die
der der ukrainischen äh Armee gemacht. Also das ist auch von außen schon so ein bisschen fischi aussieht
So und dann dann fliegen die irgendwie los und dann ballern die dann erst mal hier den ganzen Truckstau da äh irgendwie weg. So, dann dann steht Russland erstmal schön doof da oder vielleicht äh schaffen sie's sogar äh träumen wir mal weiter. Alle ihre Frontlines quasi so nennenswert zum Erliegen zu bringen.
Und noch ihre Versorgungs äh stricken ähm abzuschneiden. Was was würde dann was würde dann passieren.
Also erst mal konventionell so.
Hätte Russland gegen die USA im Wesentlichen ähm so Europa kann man da fast rausnehmen, aber also
das ist eher so ein bisschen ein i-Tüpfelchen oben oben drauf. Ähm
ja haben die einfach keine Schnitte, wenn man sich die Militäretats anguckt, also konventionell und von der Bewaffnung her und und und.
Allem so von der von der Zahl her ist äh ich sage mal die NATO ungefähr 10:1 überlegen den Russen, ja. So,
Das ist also ja, also konventionell äh
so, weil die Russen auch das Problem äh haben, gemacht haben, so historisch
kannst du dich entweder auf Langstreitkräfte fokussieren oder auf Sehstreitkräfte so. Wenn du beides
machst und nicht genug Geld hast, dann hast du als Scheiß Sehstreitkräfte und scheiß Landstreitkräfte so und in der Situation befindet sich halt
äh Russland und äh wie gesagt.
Wenn du die einfach nur die Militärbudgets äh anguckst und vergleichst, ja, NATO gegen Russland 10 zu 1, ohne äh das eins ist einzige äh sind halt die Atom,
Waffen, so die äh jetzt äh tatsächlich die NATO davon abhalten äh würde, äh abhält äh so äh dort äh die russische Armee einfach wegzubomben.
Ja gut, aber wir haben ja gerade das Szenario jetzt mal einfach in den Raum gestellt. Ja, also nicht amerikanische Truppen.
Laufen auf, sondern
the best of Breed äh von Cruise Michael, äh Technik oder was auch immer, sonst noch gerade so im Angebot ist, wird jetzt einfach massenhaft von den Amerikanern irgendwie rangekarrt und dann irgendwie in Ungarn über die Grenze rübergeschoben.
Und dann kommt das zum Einsatz so. Was würde passieren? Ist dann schon dritter Weltkrieg gleich oder.
Eigentlich könnten die Russen da nichts machen.
Also außer, außer einen Atomkrieg zu beginnen, aber also gut, da gibt's ja auch noch dann die Vorstellung, äh sozusagen von einem begrenzten Nuklearkrieg, äh wo dann nur taktische Waffen eingesetzt werden, aber
gegen was willst denn du die dann einsetzen? So also die die also was die Russen dann vielleicht tun könnten aber
Ähm also sie könnten dann halt die Nukrai die Ukraine äh könnten sie dann halt angreifen
so, aber das das würde dann sehr schnell zu einem Atomkrieg eskalieren. Ich meine, wir haben's selbst gesehen, auch schon mit dem Brand in dem Kernkraftwerk.
So dass wir zum Beispiel auch so ein Szenario, äh wenn jetzt aus irgendwelchen Gründen ein Kernkraftwerk in Brand geschossen wird
und dann die radioaktiven Schwaden äh in den in den Westen äh rüberziehen, dann.
Ja oder in den Osten aber jetzt wohin auch immer so aber speziell jetzt wenn die in den Westen äh ziehen würden äh das wäre glaube ich auch der Punkt,
äh wo die NATO-Militär schicken würde. So das würde, glaube ich, die NATO dann wiederum äh sagen, äh dann äh ja.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass das dann der nächste Eskalationsschritt äh sein könnte zum Beispiel, dass man dann sagt.
Also äh die würden dann sicherlich erst mal äh also wahrscheinlich wäre wenn Truppen geschickt.
Werden äh wäre erstmal das Szenario
dass man sagt so die sind jetzt nur zum irgendwie Schutz also würde die russischen Truppen nicht angreifen sondern sich halt erstmal hinstellen und sagen hier
so, staub jetzt und dann könnten sich die Russen überlegen äh so.
Ob sie dann sagen, die Truppen, ob sie dann in der Ukraine gegen NATO-Truppen kämpfen äh so und wie gesagt, bei dem Kräfteverhältnis äh so konventionell
hätten die Russen da einfach keine Schnitte. Ja also wir hätten da nichts wirklich wirklich aufzubieten.
Und äh so ob sie dann die nukleare Eskalation äh wirklich äh riskieren würden oder nicht. Ich meine, das ist dann jetzt Breakmanship.
So das Spiel mit dem Abgrund ähm und das kann natürlich dann auch schiefgehen, also.
Ähm ja es gibt gibt durchaus äh verschiedene Wege, wo das Ganze äh doch auch noch weiter eskalieren und auch vielleicht äh nuklear werden könnte.
Ähm was unwahrscheinlich ist, ist so ein Allout äh also äh irgendwie äh globaler Thermo nuklearer.
Krieg ähm so, dass wir sozusagen noch mal einen einen weiterer Schritt, aber ähm ja hm.
Dann das das wäre dann auch echt nicht gut fürs Klima.
Ich habe auch so schon den Eindruck, dass das alles nicht besonders gut fürs Klima abgesehen.
Nee, es ist auch.
Jetzt äh die Energiewende, die uns ohnehin schon beschleunigt wurde, äh nochmal richtig in den in den Turbo schaltet jetzt, ne. Also,
wenn jetzt sozusagen auf einmal die Agenda sagt, wir müssen jetzt innerhalb von zehn Jahren mal vom russischen Gas äh wegkommen. Im Übrigen auch noch so eine wirtschaftliche, langfristige Auswirkung, die wir noch gar nicht angesprochen haben.
Dann also allein da haben sie ja jetzt schon verloren. Also das das dass sie diesen Prozess,
in Gang gesetzt haben, ist klar. Ich meine, ich wollte sowieso schon äh bei unserem Haus mal vorsprechen, wie's mal wäre, wenn wir mal auf eine Wärmepumpe um,
steigen und habe schon irgendwie äh alle möglichen Ressourcen zusammengesucht und mir vor allem die ganze Zeit überlegt, wie argumentiere ich denn das jetzt eigentlich am besten? Und da kommst du dann so mit ja irgendwie Wertsteigerung und lalala und gucken wir uns,
eigentlich auch ganz schön und so, ne. Ähm jetzt sagst du halt einfach nur Russland und dann äh läuft der Hase.
Mhm.
Zumindest.
Ja ja da ändern sich natürlich jetzt dann auch sozusagen nochmal die ökonomischen Berechnungen, das heißt
es machen sich jetzt sozusagen alternative Energiequellen sind natürlich auch wettbewerbsfähiger geworden jetzt einfach. In dem Moment äh weil jetzt die Preise angezogen sind und auch wird sicherlich ein Schub für die Elektromobilität könnte es auch nochmal äh bedeuten jetzt wo
plötzlich der Sprit äh bei zwei Euro
Die Zwei-Euro-Marke äh mittlerweile regelmäßig überspringt. Das ist halt auch so ein so ein Ding äh so. Also ja, ja.
Insofern, ich meine in vielerlei Hinsicht haben uns die Russen eben auch dann gefallen.
Äh getan muss man sagen, die Amerikaner haben sich auch schon bedankt dafür, äh dass die Russen jetzt endlich die NATO mal wieder auf Kurs gebracht haben, dass jetzt irgendwie alle plötzlich ihre Zwei-Prozent-Ziele, wo die Amerikaner seit 20 Jahren irgendwie
rumnageln und versuchen Druck zu machen, dass das doch endlich äh ja auch Europäer eben ein Deutschland liegt. Jetzt bei.
Dass sie auch ihr Fracking äh Flüssiggas jetzt irgendwie loswerden, ne.
Ja, das ist so das andere Ding, also es herrscht halt eigentlich Überangebot auf dem äh Gasmarkt generell, also.
Ist das so?
Ja ja ja. Also äh und es wird sogar noch schlimmer, also Kanada äh äh hat jetzt jede Menge LNG-Terminals äh gebaut und bereitet sein
Einstieg äh in den LNG-Markt vor. So äh Katar weiß nicht wohin mit dem mit dem Zeugs ähm so
also der der eigentlich der der weltweite Gasmarkt oder ist halt äh ja es gibt
gibt einfach äh mehr äh Anbieter als Abnehmer oder zumindest war das äh so oder ist das auch noch so, weil Gasprommel meldete halt auch am zweiten Angriffstag, ah die Gaslieferungen laufen normal
Ja.
Das ist auch so absurd ne also.
Es war dann auch also ähm ja ähm.
Die Ukraine im Übrigen, ne.
Ukraine auch, ja. Ja also.
Oh Gott, das ist alles so crazy ey.
So also wir haben dann so die täglichen Meldungen kann man sich auch äh angucken der Durchsatz, also die Gasexporte äh und die Ölexporte laufen wohl normal,
Was halt auch, ich meine, wir haben jetzt äh die Gaspipeline standen halt alle so im Vordergrund, aber es gibt eben auch diverse Ölpipelines, äh die hier auflaufen
Und äh insbesondere gibt's hier im Osten äh gibt's eine so eine große Raffinerie, die liefert irgendwie 80 Prozent des des Benzins äh für
äh Ostdeutschland im Grunde genommen äh und die hängen äh
Ja, also an die hängen halt nicht nur an Gaspipeline, sondern auch an Ölpipelines aus aus Russland. So, das sollte man auch nicht.
Vergessen und äh über die redet halt äh nur niemand. Aber äh ja ähm und
theoretisch wär's auch durchaus möglich,
sage mal, innerhalb von zwei, drei Jahren, also das es bräuchte noch so zwei-, 3hundert mehr an äh äh,
diesen LNG Tankern. Man könnte sich Europa auch äh komplett
russischen äh Gasimporte substituieren und es gibt wie gesagt auch genug Länder, wie gesagt mit Kanada, äh die dazukommen, die USA sowieso und
äh mit dem persischen Golf äh so. Also das ist grundsätzlich genug da.
Nur Tanker gibt's grad nicht genug.
Ja. Also man müsste sagen wir um um solche Mengen jetzt zu machen müsste man wahrscheinlich über die weltweite Tanga-Flotte ungefähr verdoppeln. Aber es ist jetzt nicht Faktor zehn oder so, die man jetzt mehr bräuchte.
Und Deutschland hat halt auch noch keinen LNG Terminal, aber.
Nicht das gibt so einen Rotterdam und in Belgien.
Ja ja in Rotterdam und Belgien und Frankreich äh haben halt äh LNG Terminals, die alle nicht ausgelastet sind so.
Und ich glaube in Bremerhaven gibt's äh potenziell auch noch äh Ausbaukapazität.
Es ist, es ist eins.
Irgendwie in in Planung, aber es rechnet sich natürlich nicht, weil es natürlich billiger ist, äh irgendwie Gas durch eine Pipeline äh zu pumpen, als es erst zu verflüssigen und dann
ähm ja rüberzukarren mit einem Schiff.
Klar.
Es kann auch nur eine Übergangslösung sein, weil am Ende äh müssen wir ohnehin weg von fossilen Brennstoffen und gerade Gas fürs Heizen ist halt auch einfach ein Scheiß-Energieträger. Das geht mit Wärmepumpen äh alles sehr viel besser
das ist halt irgendwie auch äh in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung so eine Technologie ist es so und so eine krasse Schlüsseltechnologie, die kaum einer kennt.
Keiner hat keiner checkt, dass Wärmepumpen eigentlich the way out sind und dass das alles da ist und man's eigentlich nur einbauen muss.
Und dann ist der Drops gelutscht. Das ist nicht irgendwas, wo wir Lösungen finden müssen oder so. Die Lösung Gips. Das ist alles fertig. Es muss nur gebaut werden und dass wir in Deutschland.
Ist immer noch erlauben, dass überhaupt Gasheizung gebaut werden. Das ist eigentlich der Skandal. Dänemark hat da schon vor acht oder zehn Jahren.
Ein Riegel vorgeschoben. Da darf schon seit einiger Zeit überhaupt gar keine Gasheizung mehr verbaut werden
und äh dementsprechend regelt der Markt das dann halt auch. Warum gibt's das äh in Deutschland nicht schon und so? Also das sind alles solche äh äh Details. Also diese ganze Abhängigkeit von Russland, die jetzt zum Teil.
Problems ist, nicht das ganze Problem, aber ein großer Teil dieses Problems ist, dass es alles self-Inflikte und dass wir eben auch noch der CDU erlaubt haben und der SPD im Übrigen. Ähm.
In den letzten zehn Jahren, diese ganze Entwicklung der Photovoltaik und der Windkraftanlagen so in Grund und Boden zu zu äh rennen. Dafür müssen sie eigentlich auch.
Auf Ewigkeiten Abbitte leisten. Wirklich wirklich froh, dass wir diese CDU losgeworden sind und ich hoffe, die bleiben noch ganz lange weg. So,
SPD ist da nicht raus aus dem Spiel so, aber die haben jetzt die Gelegenheit irgendwie ab bitte äh zu leisten und und uns hier mal ganz schnell in die richtige Richtung zu bringen und das,
natürlich im Rahmen dieser Krise stattfinden aber jetzt müssen wir auch erstmal diese Krise in den Griff kriegen. Pavel, ich würde sagen, an dieser Stelle.
Man Punkt und ich würde sagen, für eine Auftaktssendung reicht das erstmal.
Ja und ich äh hoffe nur äh ja wir werden nicht das wird nicht der Auftakt zu einer weiteren zweijährige.
Also nee.
Reihe äh so äh aber ich ja, aber ich denke, es äh wir haben auch jetzt jetzt ganz ganz viel.
Äh sagen schon mal abgehandelt und ich hoffe äh so viel äh Neues äh wird es wird es sobald nicht nicht geben, aber wir werden werden sehen.
Ja für für die Leute da ist es natürlich 'nen Schrecken den sich keiner von uns so richtig vorstellen kann. Ich glaube.
Es ist auch noch mal eine Sache, diese Fernsehbilder zu sehen. Das ist halt schon mal schlimm genug.
Aber äh so sich selber in der in der Situation äh zu
befinden irgendwo im Keller zu hocken äh während um dich herum Dinge explodieren äh so. Das ist halt ja da weiß man halt, das macht halt auch krank äh so das erzeugt.
Äh Traumata und äh Plus natürlich dann, dass das ganze Leid und und und Tod äh und so und äh ja das ist halt natürlich alles alles.
Ziemlich schrecklich so.
Insofern schon mal ganz gut zu sehen, dass äh jetzt für die Ukraine schnell Lösungen gefunden werden. Die flüchtenden Menschen aufzunehmen. Das finde ich schon mal ganz beruhigend.
Bin ich gleich wieder so eine Debatte äh am Start haben, wie wie vor 7 Jahren.
Genau, aber das ist ja auch na ja da kommt dann natürlich jetzt auch dann wieder so gewisser Rassismus äh zum.
Das ist alles alles nicht, aber besser jetzt, besser ist es startet erstmal so und und und
in die in die Kette und das ist jetzt irgendwie klar, welchen welchen Status die haben. So da da weht schon wirklich neues Europa äh durch die Gegend, aber es ist leider derzeit alles noch ziemlicher Schwefelgeruch und es wird Zeit, dass das äh,
auf Parfüm Meer wird. Pavel, lass uns Schluss machen. Ähm Leute, das war's. Unser,
1ter Gedankenabwurf zur Ukraine-Krise. Man merkt schon, ist irgendwie eine ganze Menge in der Luft, aber vielleicht hat euch das auch geholfen, ähm erstmal so ein bisschen äh zu kontextualisieren und äh habe
äh was Neues erfahren äh dabei oder vielleicht Sachen, die er schon irgendwie wusstet, besser verbinden können.
Mhm und äh vielleicht äh widmen wir uns äh beim nächsten Mal ausführlicher der Schuldfrage. Äh es ist so.
Kommt schon wieder. Ja oder anderen Aspekten, je nachdem, was jetzt so passiert, ne. Ja.
Aber ich denke ja äh ein bisschen dann das das könnte halt vielleicht noch ein Thema sein sozusagen bisschen genauer das Ganze äh historisch nochmal aufzurollen.
Okay. Alles klar.
Ja, haltet die Ohren steif äh so und ja, hoffen wir alle das Beste, dass das so schnell wie möglich.
Aufhört, dass sich Bewahrheitet, dass die Russen angeblich nur für ungefähr zehn Tage
essen und Sprit und Munition äh haben. Die zehn Tage ja äh wären dann.
Montag, Montag tatsächlich. Ja, Montag, ja, ja. Also wir werden sehen. Oh, ich hoffe, dass bewahrheitet sich, dass den Russen einfach vielleicht auch der
Puste ausgeht und äh oder äh jetzt langsam vernünftigere Stimmen äh vielleicht die.
Oberhand äh gewinnen oder keine Ahnung äh.
Ja ein Wunder geschieht oder Putin einen Herzinfarkt erleidet oder irgendwie sowas äh Schlaganfall, wie auch immer.
Wunder halt, genau.
Na ja, mhm. Jo.